Here we go. Four, three, two, one.
Boom. And we'll live cat. How are you? I'm
good. How are you? Good to see you here.
Thanks for having me. My
pleasure. My pleasure.
I'm looking forward to talking to
you for a while. I know it's, uh,
I feel like been a long time coming.
I don't even know how much
time we have affiliate.
There's a hell of a lot to catch up on.
Yeah, there's a lot to talk about. Always.
You're a getting ready for Boise. That's
your, uh, your next fine pleats fighting.
I'm Marijn renowned, um, July 14th,
the end, the century link arena.
Now you took, you took a
good stretch off, right?
A couple of times. Yeah, a
couple of times. I, um, let's
see. After I fought Meesha,
I blew my knee and then
the world exploded in.
So I had I think 18 months off
between that and fighting, uh, Amanda.
And then after I fought Amanda,
I saw Amanda was like September 27,
something like that.
And I fought Ronda February 28th.
And then after Ronda,
uh,
took another big stretch off,
fought Juliana the following year,
July 9th,
and then this was another big stretch off.
So yeah,
it's been a little bit scattered,
but doing what I can.
Yeah, you are, you are doing
some crazy therapy to write some,
some interesting stuff down in San Diego.
Yeah. So, um, there's, there's been
a few things I've been working on,
like I'm not a huge fan of
western medicine, you know,
like, uh, even, I mean,
you can call it alternative medicine.
It's like original medicine. I,
I appreciate looking at things like that
way more than, you know, big farm. But I,
uh, you know, one thing that, um,
you know, fighting has gotten me and,
and stuff with, you know, I think
it's more prevalent in women,
although I'm thinking it's
happening with men too,
is like our endocrine systems are not
happy with these weight cuts and they're
not happy with us. Like getting hit in
the head a lot of go figure. Right? Yeah.
So, um, you know, within all
of that I've just, you know,
had medical problems and things that
like I'm constantly working on and I feel
really good. I'm, I'm
constantly improving. But, um,
one thing I was feeling a
little bit stuck on was a wine,
I like some of the endocrine problem
issues, but, um, like I dunno,
I, I had, uh, had I went
to this facility in,
in San Diego is called, um,
Dang, why can't I remember, oh,
a mindset. And actually the UFC sent
me there because I mean, we have Usada,
we have all of these things
like, um, after fighting Amanda,
I got my head pounded for a
good four minutes there. Um,
I had a Tbi afterwards,
so that was like, uh,
immediately lowered my,
a estrogen lured my da ta,
my testosterone and I'm hypo thyroid.
Like I will always be hyperthyroid now.
Like I have to that fight. Yeah. Yeah.
And um, you know, still toughed it out.
So it was trying to do what I could
to go and fight Ronda as soon as I did
afterwards. And, you know,
part of my game plan is don't
get hit and which means like,
let's just dart out her and see
what happens. You know? So what,
that's what happens when you do that.
No, Tbi is traumatic brain injury just
in case if someone is listening to this
doesn't understand what we're talking
about. And then in the Rhonda fight,
if people don't know about that,
you just charged after and he got caught
in an arm bar and like, what was it?
Very quick,
14, 13, 14 sayings. But I did hit
her with a knee. I did throw her ass,
but she practiced a little Ninja
move and comedy alarm and it was,
it was over, you know, but I mean
even even her coaches were like,
you did what you're supposed to do there.
And She just got you. You know? So, um,
that would be an awesome fight to be
able to revisit one day as she even said
we'd do it. I mean, who knows her career
so open right now. She need to really,
I don't think she wants to.
I think,
I mean, who knows? You'd have to ask her,
but there's a lot of
lessons to be learned.
And what happened to her in terms of like
all of the distractions and Hollywood
came calling and there were scripts and
talk about doing road house and there
was all this, all this shit going on.
There was other than fighting, you know,
and then it was also,
look,
the sport has evolved so
rapidly in the women's,
women's MMA has gotten so high
level so quickly. And if you,
I'm sure you saw a man to his last
fight with Raquel Pennington, I'm like,
Holy Shit.
I mean that was a fucking,
the high level performance
from her and five rounds,
super high cardio, just put a
beating down and Raquel painting,
it's one of the toughest
girls in the world for sure.
Right? I do like, I mean I'm curious,
I was saying the same thing as the
fights going. Right. And then I have, uh,
some people in my ear next to me,
they're like,
well how long has it been since we're cal?
Fuck,
cause she didn't look her
or like [inaudible] she,
she looked a little tired.
She looked a little like not
her typical and then it's,
it's like she's a year and
a half off herself. Right.
Like right into a title fight,
which I have to say I'm a little bit
envious of because when I beat Misha,
I, when, uh, I was supposed
to coach ultimate fighter,
but that was all ultimately going to
end up in a title shot with Rhonda and I
blew my knee and my husband passed away
and there was like a long moment of
silence in there. And then when I was
able to come back, they made me read,
earn my title shot, you know? And so it
was like, wait, oh, we're doing that now.
Or just like
what would attractive
contenders are available.
Yeah, it looks good. I agree. Yeah.
I mean it was very young at that,
at that age or at that at the time.
Right. And in Bantam weight
right now there's like,
there's no standout contender and Raquel
had beaten some really good fighters
and she looked like the next in line.
And did she blow her knee out as well?
I want to say she got
like, Oh, I could be lying,
but I think she got like some
accident with a four wheeler,
like rolled over and broke
her leg or something.
I could like totally be
making that up though.
She could have just twisted it walking
down the street too. So I don't know.
Yeah. Now that you're saying that,
I do remember something like a Bro,
a broken leg, Jamie, you'll
find out what it is. Um,
but were you a,
were you surprised by that fight
between Raquel and Amanda?
Yeah, I mean, I didn't,
I didn't see where cal being the
one to beat her, you know. Um,
I do feel like Amanda's been working and
doing like, you know, improving, I mean,
she changed her camps.
The coaches that she's working with.
I tried out for a while at,
at one point too when I was trying
to find my spot and they're legit.
They're very good.
Um,
and American top team has a lot
of high level training partners,
both girls and guys, you know
what I mean? She had a good, uh,
a good decision made there. So
I, I see how she's improved. Um,
I think with the time off with Raquel,
I wasn't sure how it was going to go,
but also I just,
I just don't know.
I just don't see Raquel being to
be being the one that beats her.
It's so hard to tell
you no, right. I mean,
anybody on any given night at the
highest level, the game someone can,
when someone can be off,
someone can be a hard, yeah,
there's no math to be done in this sport.
There really isn't a,
math is ridiculous. So, I mean,
sometimes I hear like statistics on me
or definitions on me or labels on me and
I'm like, wait, I'm a,
I'm a known striker. Like,
I'd never would've thought I'd
be known as a striker. I mean,
I've been doing Jujitsu and wrestling
my whole life slog me and I'll take it.
Fuck yeah. You know? Yeah,
yeah, yeah. But even that is,
yes. But I mean that,
that in itself was like,
I love to wrestle and what can I
do once I've closed that distance?
While it's those, those short and
goals strikes, you know, there's,
there's needs and there's elbows there
that those are the most destructive
things I could possibly do to
someone when, when we're that close.
And to do all that work to get that close.
But granted,
that's all influenced by my time, what
I got to learn from that discipline. So,
you know, it's all relevant,
but um, you know, it's, uh,
it's always just interesting to hear
how you're now being categorized.
Yeah, it is weird. Right? But you are,
you are definitely a dangerous striker.
I mean,
you're dangerous.
I agree. I mean, I like it and, and I'm,
I'm enjoying constantly learning
and new things like the,
the basics were always hard for me to
get cause I wanted to do the big girl
stuff, you know, and uh,
you know, found my way,
like right in the middle of all of that.
And,
and find a way to use how
aggressive I am and how,
just like Dominique domineering, I can
feel in there and all of that. So it's,
it's like, I don't know, the,
I want the maximum amount of
damage without taking damage,
which is obviously the goal. Right.
But like I want to put it into a dance,
so it's like a little,
I don't know.
What made you decide to go to San
Diego? So you were at alliance now? Um,
moved from Colorado to San Diego.
A few things. So one of
them, one of them was like,
Colorado is a complicated situation for
me. I mean, I had gyms that they're like,
a lot just happened up there.
Um,
and I love my team elevation. Like I
love ice. I'm still close with everybody.
Like I go to Colorado for Christmas
holidays, I get still home, you know,
but a couple of things. One
with the head injury. Um,
Colorado is amazing for training,
right? It's amazing for building your,
your endurance and whatever.
But it is not good for healing.
Like you'll never see a doctor tell
someone with Alzheimer's or a Tbi or heart
problems or even like massive
allergies or um, what's the,
uh,
arthritis arthritis like those are not,
that's not a good place
for people to live with.
Any kind of inflammatory or like major
thing that needs to be healing because
your body's already working at
such a high level because yeah,
because the altitude, I mean the
thin air, the, the things like that,
it's just like I spent so
much time and so much money,
like figuring out what the hell
was wrong with me that, you know,
I ended up at the Mayo clinic spending
weeks at a time going to all their like
specialized different,
uh,
doctors and situations like that
for them to tell me like, you know,
if you want to heal, you want to give
yourself the best opportunity to hill,
you're probably not going
to do it up at altitude.
Like we would prefer seeing
you at sea level. Um,
so combined like I kind of,
I needed to almost exiled myself from
Colorado cause I want to love it.
And I was starting to, it was starting to
get like less colorful for me, you know,
cause I felt like I had the best there
was as far as coaches and the best there
was as far as training partners and the
situations like everything was as good
as it was going to get. Like it literally
was as good as it was going to get.
And it was like this can't be it.
Like I don't feel, I don't feel right.
No. And, and I was like, that means I'm
gonna have to take a change. You know,
when I was scared,
like I have a little boy,
like I'm taking them away from everything
we know and we just packed a u haul
and we left and we got to San
Diego in San Diego I went,
I wish I had written down like all the
gyms I went to and showed up at like
anonymously to, because I
didn't want them to, like,
I wanted to kind of catch them
with their pants down. Like,
what are you guys like right
now versus if you're prepared,
I don't want to show up and have
you have people here watching me.
I don't want you to put on a show,
like I want to catch you how you are and
like have you decide what you think of
me too. Because these needs,
this needs to be a fit. I mean,
fighting and coaching and training is
very intimate and it needs to be authentic
and real. The days I'm sitting there,
ugly white girl crying on the ground,
but I need,
I need you to tell me to keep,
stay on the erudite and you know what I
mean? Like, just let me cry, you know,
that kind of thing. And um, it's, uh,
so I went to all these places and like I,
the best part about it is that I got to
learn and train with so many fighters in
so many coaches that I like.
I'm so excited about the relationships
I made and the people I know. But, um,
like all of them, it was like, this
is awesome, but it's not the place.
This is awesome,
but it's not the place I came up to.
And I was very close to
going to American top team.
They had an awesome deal set up for
me to go, like helping me with my kid,
helping me with a good percentage
for training, like how uh,
living situation was going to be, they're
going to accommodate me really well. Um,
but when it was time to like pack my
car and go like something was like that
wasn't it, you know? And so I'm like,
I mean sweaty all the time,
like right here,
like in that look hot,
there's a lot of cool people in Florida,
but there's just,
there's some subhumans down there.
Yeah. I really appreciate it.
Like the Latin culture. I
mean, I'm all about, yeah,
it's Florida.
There's some fucking swamp people though.
There is no joke, no joke. Um, so, uh,
then I looked west, you know, um, I know
ed stores out here, he's my manager and,
and I had it a few pockets of people I
knew that can maybe be a support to me
and my kids. So, um, came to
la. If I was here, I was going
to go to the black house.
Uh, I think, um, uh, oh,
where's Kelvin Gastelum train again?
12 and gasoline.
You got to say his name wrong every time.
But where is he coached the
MEU ticket kings. Kings,
Kayla's going to kings black house.
And I was still trying to pick Jujitsu.
Like I wanted like a art of
Jujitsu guy or, or uh, you know,
just someone really good.
Yeah,
because I came from
traditional traditional
Jujitsu and like I love MMA and
mixing it up,
but I need that.
So I felt you were introduced to
purple for like ever like six years.
How come? So long? Because I'm being
a Weirdo about who promotes me.
Cause my husband,
my husband promoted me to probe about
and like I really want what whoever takes
over their lineage to be like that.
Like I don't want it a different
one from 10 different people.
Like I want that like I want
to pick and it be right.
And so actually now I'm super excited
because I just started training at Aptos
and I have so much respect for
Andre and his wife Angelica.
There's so many good fighters come out
of that gym to Great Jujitsu fighter. I,
I've been changing there
like four weeks now and I've,
I mean I've trained there before but like
every day for weeks now and I've only
had like one day where I walked
out feeling like a rock star.
The rest of the days they were whooping
my ass but it was good, you know,
like I needed that and it
tells me, you know, yeah.
And there it's just been so good and to
see myself that way and to hold people
that way.
Like I was the jit at Jujitsu me and I
was like killing it on the circuit for a
long time and then Emma May comes in and
puts this pressure on like even those
kinds of competitions, even though
they're not even the same animal.
And I'm annoyed that I let that bother
me and keep me from competing in between
fights because I loved that name in MMA.
You feel
weird about competing in Jujitsu
tournament? I think I did. I,
or maybe I thought I'd pick up
bad habits or I would do whatever,
but because maybe other people had
that experience, but like for me,
I need to see it for myself. Like if I
go and I do a tournament and I do great,
then hell yeah, I'm going to have higher
expectations of myself in a fight.
If I go and I do shitty. Okay, well,
like now I get to learn
like that competing is where
I get to learn everything
and spacing out these competitions.
Especially at the time I've had to take
off in between fights. Like I'm not,
I don't believe necessarily in ring rust,
but like when they say go,
I don't know what go means until a
little bit later than I'm expecting.
And it's been the pattern
in these last two fights.
You mean when the fight starts, you still
feel like, is this really happening?
Kind of. Well, even this last
night, this last fight with Caitlin,
like we got in and I was like, do I
remember what to do here? You know,
and I was like, fuck it,
I'm just a throw bombs.
And the whole time I was
just like, and I'm not eat,
that's not me there, you know,
it was just like chucking my hands at
her and hoping they land and if they
didn't like the fuck out, you know,
you feel like out of composure. Yeah,
until the,
until the third round.
And then the third round I was
awake and ready to go. And I mean,
I felt warmed up. I felt
right. And you know,
she was looking at the clock and backing
up and all of this and I was just like,
come here, come here. Like I'm ready to
fight finally, like come here. And uh,
you know, I don't know. So there's
something to be fixed about that.
And I don't think it's a
secret, but, um, I dunno.
I think maybe something with the warmup
I need to like fully like have like a
respiratory exhaustion before I go in
so I can simulate those first rounds.
Beating the hell out of the way.
Even in wrestling, I don't know.
You know, there's, there's
a lot to it. Like, Gosh,
we're bouncing around all these different
things. But I mean, one thing with the,
with that treatment center that I went
to is like, um, doing different things,
like dealing with your psychology, dealing
with like the synchrony in your brain,
you know,
having your brain function and then on
the same hurts at the same or different
areas of your brain. What did
they do exactly? So it's therapy.
So it's these magnets, right? Like
the, the main people in there. I mean,
it's beautiful.
Not Beautiful but beautiful to
see sitting in the lobby waiting.
When you see people with
Alzheimer's come in,
like there's a man that wheels his wife
and every day and, and you can't, you can,
I think at the beginning of the week she
gets like an ivy so she's like a little
bit more up and Chipper, but by
the end of the week, you know,
she's a little bit more slouch and,
and stories like his,
where he's talking about, um, you know,
before they started going in there,
she would just go to the bathroom all
over and every day this man takes care of
his wife,
puts her makeup on her,
like goes and gets her hair done even
though she doesn't even know, you know,
and now she can at least tell him that
she needs to go to the bathroom. Like,
just be like, hey, it's time, you know,
and he can get her there and you know,
sort of,
kind of have like meaningful moments
that they haven't had in awhile for,
there's a ton of veterans in there and
active veterans to active military guys
that are,
they're doing these door breaches and
then they get their head rattled up too
many times and they're noticing they have
problems with some depression. I mean,
and these are high level
navy seals, high level, like,
like special forces that need, um,
need. They're expensive people.
They've,
there's millions of dollars poured into
these people and they're not ready to
let them go yet. So they're
like, how can we fix them,
give them this like performance edge
but still get them like he like healed
enough. But we need, we need to throw them
back in there. We need them, you know?
And so I've had to sit in on appointments
with the Department of Defense in talk
about my experience with it. I
had to, uh, I, I don't, I don't,
there's some really famous people I don't
even think I get to say cause I'd be a
dick and I'm probably be in trouble, but,
um, that I've sat in on and you know,
they've had their own issues
with mental health or PTSD or um,
uh,
they're like autism,
different things like family members of
theirs or whatever that I've sat in on
and kind of been helpful in talking
about because I went in there on two
different antidepressants. Um, and these,
I was put on at the Mayo Clinic and
felt like post the Nunez. Yeah, this
is how crazy am. I mean math is right.
You lose to Rhonda in 14 seconds.
You Kao Amanda Nunez,
Amanda Nunez beats the shit
out of Rhonda and 48 seconds.
That's, that's, you might be like
the perfect example. I'm a math,
you know, and I mean crazy. It's crazy.
I need you beaten down to UFC champion.
Well, in it, I mean, I took, it took
two and a half rounds for me to,
for me to sub Pennington too.
You know,
like there's nothing like,
you know, but who is it?
Pennington goes toe to toe
and round around with Holly.
Holly Knox Out Rhonda Too.
Like it's just this division.
His fight with Ashley.
Evan Smith to this day that the ending,
when she got her in that bulldog choke.
Oh Robert and blood and finished
her like literally one second.
It was a violent, crazy. I, I
screamed so loud at the end of that.
It was just fucking chaos.
That was, she's done.
She's had two fights that ended like
that with like one second to go.
She finishes the fight.
It's tough girl. So the,
anyway, MMA math is
ridiculous. It doesn't work.
And you might be the best example of how
it doesn't work, but so you go to this,
the, the Mayo Clinic puts you
on antidepressants because
you just feel like shit.
He like
shit. And because like the different
endocrine problems that I had,
right. So I can't have any of the
medications that'll help that.
So I have to be more conservative with it.
And one way they thought to
do it is because my cortisol
levels are really high.
They're talking about, um, and I
mean granted I have a lot of stress,
especially like, you know,
life hasn't been easy
fast. Like mom, your husband
passes away toughest,
probably the toughest sport on the planet,
trying to be the best at it. So yeah,
elite,
you're in the top 10 so you're,
you're in this weird position where you
never know when you're going to fire to
who you're going to find.
There's a constant amounts to,
and it's not like you're making
millions of dollars doing it either.
No. Well, and it's
expediting healing for me in,
and I also have a kid going
through what I'm going through,
so it's not like I get to like split
and cut corners and just, you know,
it's like there's maintenance to be done
at all times with that. So I go there,
they tell me,
you know,
we could probably lower your coders all
levels if we could load or lower your
stress levels. So we'll try
it. Antidepressants, what
did that make you feel like?
Flat as fuck. And like I didn't get my,
can I say fuck on this? Cause I said okay.
I know, I just didn't know if I have
a quota for, I'm like a bad person.
Like did I get handed to like a duck?
It added to a certain level,
zero restrictions. You can say whatever
you want in the shit out of it. Okay.
So got it. Um, so yeah,
they,
they put me on the flat flat,
which like all that training camp
getting ready for Juliana. I'm just like,
I'm like, okay, I'll, it'll,
it'll take off in the fight.
Like I feel good in the fight. Like
when they say no ups, no downs,
no, no pissed off, like want to
kill, you know, nothing, you know,
and not scared but not
happy. No. And I was like,
why am I not nervous the way
that I get nervous? Like,
like I was okay, which you usually
like, especially two weeks out,
I have this like flesh of
emotions, you know, where I'm like,
fetal position in the corner, like
what the fuck? And then once it's over,
all I want to do is kill, you know. But,
uh, like, and I didn't have that either.
What kind of made me nervous because my,
my other friend buyer pancheck we, she,
she's a new 20 fiver.
Um,
we would always like call each other and
laugh at how dumb we are being at that
point. Like look at me, you know. And uh,
but that was all gone with the
shit that they put you on. Um, oh,
it was this one. Oh my gosh. Keep going.
PROZAC. What other have,
do you know what I mean?
Jeremy affects her Effexor and stupid
crazy pills twice a day. Just tic tacs.
So they put you on this stuff
and did they try different ones?
Uh,
no because a lot of time there isn't,
you know, and, and they're
looking, I'm like, I need the side,
this side effects matter.
Like these can be ones that
made me gain a bunch of weight.
They can't make me like I need
to still be able to sleep.
Like I have to be able to have like
enough highs, lows to be able to
function and learn and,
and whatever.
And so this is like the best they
could have for me. So anyway,
I fight that fight with
Juliana. You know, I,
I feel like the first round I
came out how I wanted, you know,
and then halfway through the second round,
like it was just awful.
Like she had my old coaches in her corner.
You know what's weird about that fight
is I could hear you and I could like, I,
this is where the flat
came in is like I wasn't,
I didn't feel like I was in the fight.
Like I could see her beans feet and I
could hear you talking about us and I,
I saw like I could hear Juliana's
coaches and it was breaking my heart.
They were coaching against me because
they were my Colorado gym and she went and
trained with them and I know she had
trained with them previously. So I mean,
before she had taken the fight. But to me
it was like fucked up to here, you know?
And it hurt me in a way, like it's,
I wish I could explain it better,
but it was like I heard them and I
just wanted to go home. You know,
I look at the clock and I'm like,
can this just be over?
I don't want to go back to Colorado.
I want to move.
Like I literally on this side of the cage,
I had my past in Colorado,
I had these coaches, I had the
drama with that, with that Jim,
like how everything went and,
and then on this side it was like all
new problems like San Diego, Eric,
and then we're good. Like there was
a lot of training partners there.
It was sunny, it was similar to Colorado
at different but in the right ways,
you know? And it was like,
I just wanted it out. Okay.
You were in San Diego trainer for
that fight or no? Yeah, I can't,
I just flew out for it. For, for the
training camp and why you flew out there,
you were still taking the antidepressants
and did that fight convince you to
stop taking them?
Yeah. So after that fight
I went to a, what did I do?
I think I went to the,
I was at the Pi,
I was working with Novinski and
people on like what to do about that.
I haven't talked to Gordon.
Dr. Gordon Moore. Gordon. Yeah.
To help me with all of that too.
Cause he thought there was
a more conservative way to
help me with those issues
as well. And so I knew I was talking
with him. I had him talk to them. Uh,
they were all trying to figure out a way,
but still there's like,
there's no way to even just naturally
bring you up. I'm thinking about retiring.
Yeah. And that, that's the thing is the
center was really the place that was,
is like, okay, I'm going to go
here. I've tried everything else.
I'm going to go here and if they
can't fix me then, then I'm,
I'm going to have to be done.
How crazy is that?
How fucking hard is Amanda Nunez hit?
It's nuts.
She does it like she,
I don't want to say she hits like a dude
cause that's kind of weird, you know.
But, uh, yeah, it's uh,
I remember being surprised.
I remember like having this open guard on
the ground and kind of like, come here,
you know, like I dare you. And then
she hit and I was like, Oh, oh,
oh you have those
and that you could see the look on
people's face when she hits him.
Like where you saw it
Rhonda like right away. Yeah
there's a part in that fight.
Cause I watched our fight
after and like you, uh,
she hit me and it like did say I think
it's right when it had to be when I hurt
my head cause it like drop my
arm and it dropped my neck.
And I just remember like seeing like the
little twin eat tweety birds and I was
pumped because I was like,
that's where the cartoons get it from.
Cause somebody explained that shit.
That's exactly where they got it.
It's like woo. And uh, and my arm,
like I couldn't get my arm back up and
I remember listening to you and you're
like, cousin not intelligently
defending herself. I'm like, listen Joe,
that fucker won't work.
You know?
And then she screwed up
because she grabbed my knee
and my knee was the one that
was like the catalyst to all my
problems over the last couple of years.
And it was just like, don't fucking touch
that. And after that it was just like,
I just angry when she grabbed you
in. Yes. Who's the wrong knee?
But I knew what she was
trying to do. Right. Yeah.
And then on top of that it's
like, it's just, I don't know,
the rest of it was just
like punishing her.
She's Kinda like Sassy before the
fight anyways. Like in awkward ways,
like not even like cool hypey ways,
like just staring at me really weird in
a room where it was just like me and Tim
Kennedy sitting there eating
like watermelon and stuff
after ins and I look over
and she's just like staring at me all
weird. I was like, Damn. Tim's like,
dude, what do we do? I'm like,
I can throw out a plate, a watermelon
water. I can throw a table. I don't know.
I don't know what tone we're doing here.
Right.
Wow. When, uh, when you stopped her.
We've played the recording
of you screaming like maybe
10 times on this podcast
because to this day,
that is one of the Ra's moments
I've ever seen inside the octagon.
Like when you, when you jump, like when
they stopped that fight and you screamed,
it was fucking bone chilling. It was,
it's so, I mean, I'm sure you've heard it,
but that here it is right here.
Play at Jamie.
That's like from your genes. That's
like, that's some cellular level shit.
Yeah, that's intense. Hey
Leaf. It's like I didn't
like, like we lived, you know,
like we lived, they didn't,
we, we get to eat. They don't,
and you know, it's, it's,
it's, it's a relief. It's,
Oh yeah, yeah. I mean you were,
like you said you lived, cause that
was, I mean, look, it's just a fight.
There is a referee,
you're going to be saved.
But one of the things that George Saint
Pierre said last week when he was on the
podcast, he said, the mentality that
you go in there, the way you fight,
you are a warrior. Like you, you
know that you're going to be rescued,
but you are fighting for your life.
And when you're fighting a fucking
killer like Amanda and you get lit up,
like you didn't survive that first
round and then go back and stop her.
That's where that comes from.
I mean that was just fucking tense.
Well it's the, it's the practicality
to me, right? Like, yes, exactly.
We have a referee, we have cage walls,
we have whatever, you know, fans,
it's entertaining people.
But like I need to know,
I need to know that like, well
that'd be a nature, you know,
that'd be doing whatever
that be self defense that be,
oh fuck us fighting over a
territory or food or whatever.
Like I need to know what would happen.
Like if we had like that's
why I want these finishes.
We only get 15 minutes to be able to tell
ourselves what would have happened in
that situation. You know? And,
and when it goes to a decision,
I'm pissed cause I don't know,
you know, like you don't know,
especially these three round fights where
I'm waking up like these last couple
fights, like late in the fight,
I'm pissed because I'm like,
I don't know if that would have been
another 30 minutes or another two hours
that we're scrapping in the woods.
Like who gets the bone? You know,
I want to know. And, and so that's, it's,
it's crazy and issue of
practicality and the sheer survival.
And this is the way I get to know myself.
That's deep. Who gets the bone? Ooh.
Damn the way you just put it.
No,
I don't think I've ever heard anybody
put it that way. You need to know.
Yeah, that's intense. But I get it.
I get it. That's where that's
cream comes from. You got the bone.
So you go down to San Diego. What was
your shortlist before, by the way?
I'm a huge fan of, uh, Eric. Uh,
alliance is just one of the best camps
for sure. And I think Eric Delphia,
it's like probably one
of the most underrated.
And because he doesn't toot his own
horn. Yeah. He's like in the shadows,
laid back, doesn't want any intention.
She's not trying to get any attention.
Like he's the last guy to like request
attention, you know, but super,
super knowledgeable and one of
the best guys in a corner too.
Like his advice is always excellent.
I never,
never heard him say the wrong thing in
the corner. He's always like on point.
But what was your short list of
places to go to besides the wines?
Um, I went to, did you
go to New Mexico by? Yes,
but I feel like I'm not trying to walk
in on Holly and like make sure weird.
Then they were going to fight each other
at some point. I know. And that just,
you know, I don't want to be that guy,
you know? Although I know I'm welcoming.
I know that everyone
there always been nice.
I've gone and train there
before and it's been good. Um,
but it's just not a
cool move, you know? Um,
I went down to Arizona with crouch.
Loved it there. Another great guy. Yeah.
Great. I feel the same way about him.
He same. Yeah. Very, very,
very humble. Very good.
I'm super knowledgeable to up in La.
La was cool,
but it was a lot of that
driving around in the
traffic and congestion and I
couldn't sacrifice the like
the um, yeah. Is, is so many people here.
Yeah.
And,
and coming from Colorado and coming from
like chill out doorsy you can drive 20
minutes and be somewhere no one's ever
stood before too, like stuck in traffic,
breathing air.
You don't want to breathe like,
like everyone's a little pissed off,
but no one really knows why Jan is right.
Jamie's been saying this forever.
Yeah.
Yeah. Where would you go? Maybe
Colorado is so dope. Get their
food culture could be better there.
I wish we could combine that food
culture of culture. What do you went to?
I mean, I mean I'm, I'm in a health food.
I mean like ethnic food. I like every,
I like, I like trying new stuff all the
time. I'm not very like Food Cheney,
you know, I'm in a fire and meat.
Yeah. Are you are, you know,
it's so good. So good. So I've decided
I was go for the steak.
First of all, it's a great,
I love vegetables, but you can get them
anywhere. I can get them in Colorado.
Not really. I mean it's not exactly
the produce capital of the world,
but you can get them. Yeah. It's not
the best. Yeah. Just get a greenhouse,
grow some tomatoes on my spare
time. Yeah. Did you try Montreal?
Did you think about five
star? I, I did not. Well,
I thought about it but um, I don't,
I didn't get up to Canadia. Aye. Aye.
I went to Thailand,
I went to Mexico.
I went to you think about
going to Thailand. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean when I'm there especially, it's
like such, it's a Buddhist culture.
People are so happy.
I mean that you have your shit.
They're just like you have everywhere
else. But at the same time like,
like the Moyie Thai training is good.
I know the places I would go to Jujitsu,
the fair techs and pet TRS is,
is coming around in,
in pretty solid.
Like,
I've been considered that for this camp
just to kind of like make some changes
cause I really want to have that
influence and that like exposure to the
authentic when we tag.
And like when I looked back at my most
successful and most happy times after
these three fights, I've lost three
in a row. Like that doesn't happen.
I'm not saying, you know, I'm like, no,
I'm better than this. Like something's up.
And I know there's a lot that I need
to work on. I mean like, uh, my, uh,
my life in general and I'm doing it and
I'm happy to be doing it and I'm happy
to be getting the lessons, even if this
is how I have to get him. Like fuck it.
At least I know. So, um, I tried
to look back and analyze like,
what was I doing when I
was my favorite fighter,
when I was feeling the best and
it was like very traditional,
thick Moitai in very traditional tech,
Jujitsu.
So that this camp has been something that
I'm gonna also be outsourcing because
I want to be like that
element. So I'm doing my, I'm doing an
actual Moitai with John Ex. He's uh, uh,
Jeremy Stevens, Muy Thai coach I think
too. And then my Jujitsu with Attos.
And then, cause before it was like I
would do these separate disciplines,
put them together and drills and sparring
and then go mango people and then like
have fun with it.
Cause it's like these little goals I
had set this little bucket list I would
take into a fight with me and try to pull
those things off and that and then go
learn new stuff and then go
try to do that. That's why
I was constantly evolving.
Every fight,
even the fight with Amanda and I like
snapped her down and I had her by her head
and everyone's screaming news
news and like hold my beer.
And that's what I go to throw
her with the, you know, the
old, they call it a DDT.
I it wasn't, it was a freestyle like
front headlock suplex but it was like,
like I want, I want every fight to be
different and fun. Like know what I have,
but see what else I got
right thing. And, and that,
that I don't even get to play that right
now because I'm fucking up and I'm,
I'm not doing what I want in these fights.
So I decided to take steps backwards.
And how do you start and
training and training? I,
I don't know. It, it's something's,
something's been missing and I'm partially
wondering if it's that, you know,
so like every fight I'm looking
to make improvements and change.
Like I'm not going to ever sit here and
say I know everything and that it's just,
I have no excuses. Katelyn found a
way to beat me, you know what I mean?
Juliana found a way to beat me.
I kinda beat myself in that one too,
cause I let my head get into my,
you know, and that sucked in again,
another thing for me to have put time
in and I'm happy I did, but I mean,
that got me to move to San Diego. So I
mean, I'm, I'm happy for that message.
It costs me a lot of money
to get that message, but I'll
take it. Um, and Caitlin,
yeah. She found a way to beat me in, into,
have been beaten by Jujitsu when I feel
very accomplished in Jujitsu that like
stung differently.
You know,
it's done way differently than just
someone else getting their hand raise.
Do you feel when you're in training
that you're the same as you were before,
when you were at your best?
Um, when I was at my best, no, but it's
something I'm working on. Like I have,
I know I have like the
hangups that I have. I know
there's a ton of mental stuff,
you know, one, um, just how life
happened and, and constantly having,
like I had this expedited adaptation
to training. I had to get new coaches,
I had to find new gyms,
I had to do all of this while
in grief and being under like,
like this isn't the most forgiving
crowd, you know, like when,
when you're having a shit day,
definitely not the worst. It's crazy.
It's crazy because it's such a,
like you're so exposed and you're so
vulnerable as a fighter and the fans might
be the meanest.
Well and yes,
there is so mean and,
but I feel like I have the best fans too.
Like I have the ones,
the ones that really old, there's no
ride or die and like I'm so proud of him,
but um, like I didn't even start
doing my own social media. My,
my husband did my social media and so
all of a sudden I get thrown in to social
media and how social media works when I'm
at my most like low vulnerable and all
that shit.
I didn't know you're not supposed to,
I'm looking at it like investments, right?
Like I'm like, Oh, here's the stock.
I'm going to put money into this stock
and let's just see how it turned out.
I was like,
ah.
And I think the first person that ever
told me not to do that was callin like
later, he's like, never read the
cop. What are you doing Brian?
Cal doesn't reach because I don't
read the comments, but I'm like,
well how will I know how I did?
He's like, just fucking no in here.
Peers, you're, no, you'll know from your
coaches and you'll know, you'll know.
Well it's,
I mean it's sex when you know,
like six hours later you wrote some shit
that people are taking wrong or I mean
it's like an opportunist situation.
They like wait for you to
fuck up and they're like,
oh, right there, right there.
I'm like, you know, I didn't mean
to say that or you know what?
That's not how I meant it or whatever.
But hard
because everybody's text looks the same.
Yeah.
The tax that you would get from a Holly
Holm or someone you respect versus a
text he get from some fat slob
sitting there eating Cheetos,
farting into their hands.
The same person.
Like it looks the same as on text,
but it's just you're going to get like
some people that just want to hurt your
feelings because they suck
and their life is terrible.
Like I've never met a hater that's
doing great. Like there's no, no.
Haters are like, man, my fucking life is
awesome. But you know what I liked doing?
I go on Youtube and I just go make
comments that are just trying to hurt
someone's feelings.
I just try to cut them to the bone.
Just say fucked up shit about dead
relatives, what they did wrong.
Those people were all just losers,
just fucking losers, you know? I mean,
there's just no way around it.
That's all they are.
It was so foreign to me because I mean
in wrestling, like I did wrestling,
I did soccer, volleyball, swimming.
Like I never ever heard
anyone be discouraging like
no one ever came to me and
was like, fuck you. You
suck. Yeah, you wouldn't
get that from someone
who was a fan or someone.
Even if someone's from an opposing
team and like she ain't shit this.
They're just saying that because they
want to beat you. You know? It's like,
but the, the haters that you're
dealing with online, they
just, there's a lot. Look,
life is fucking complicated.
It's hard to get right and as you're
seeing with your very difficult career,
there's, there's a lot of like
decisions to be made. There's you,
you can fuck it up. You got to
build back up again. Try. Right?
And you're a smart person who's
strong and successful for losers.
Life is impossible.
It's impossible.
And so they go through life just angry
and depressed and sad and failing at
everything they do.
But they still have a phone or they still
have a laptop and like you fucking con
flooding loser. And that's what you're
getting. That's what you're getting.
You're getting the all that anger
and you didn't even know this person.
Why are they angry at you?
Because they're angry at life because
life is fucked him in the ass.
That's they're angry.
They're angry at life because they
got dealt a shit existence. Right?
They have bad genetics, they have
a bad family, they have a bad job,
they live in a bad neighborhood, they have
bad people around them. They feel bad,
everything's wrong. And,
but they still get to talk.
They still get to talk shit and
they still get to type things,
type mean things out.
That's,
that's why he can't read
comments cause it's fucking,
the only thing you could do is inspire
with your work with you what you do.
And you do that already, you
know, and you're a human being.
You're gonna make mistakes and you're
going to do things right and going to do
things wrong,
and you're going to have these epic
moments and you're going to have these
failures because that's just a part of
like doing things that are complicated,
but you can't read the comments.
You definitely can't take them to heart.
Noted. Yes, no. Did he got me
good a couple of times I get, Oh,
fuck up your day. Yeah, day.
Yeah. Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ken, what then happened? It's sad
because those people that are doing that,
they're in pain.
This is the know,
the only reason why they would lash
out at you like that and they go, no,
I'm just telling the truth.
Who just can't handle the truth.
Even if it was the truth.
The way in which people say it in the
reason why they're saying is because they
want to hurt your feelings.
They're not being kind. You know,
there's a lot of that going on today.
I mean even then, even in the media,
the way people tell stories and write
stories and write articles about people,
it's like they're not,
this is not just that.
They're trying to tell the facts
and explain what's happening.
They're trying to cut people down
and hurt people and it's, this is,
I wonder how much of it has to do with
the fact that our fucking president does
that because it seems more
prevalent now than ever before.
It seems like there's like a trend and
I think a lot of like one of the things
about the president,
whoever the president is,
it's like there's some people that are
not going to listen to anything he says,
but there's a certain amount of people
that are gonna take his actions and use
it as almost like a barometer.
Yeah.
Example of how they should behave
and how this country behaves.
It's like he's the top dog and when the
top dog is insulting people all the time
and saying shitty things and holds
it can be successful. Yeah. It's,
it lets people know there's, or you
want to get ahead. I want to get ahead.
You got to do like him and then they, they
go out and act like assholes too. Yeah,
that's a bummer. So anyway, you
go down to San Diego and what,
what are they doing for you that gets
you off of the antidepressants and gets
you feeling better?
Whoa. Uh, it's again, like you get in
there and I mean it's, it's scary to go.
Again, like I said, there's, there's
all these different people in there.
The man found the, the
research on it by, um,
treating his own autistic kid and,
and you can see the before
and after videos of this kid
and it's like, damn. Okay.
And then, um, I brought my son into,
cause he has ADHD and he's off
his medication now as well.
So I'm going in there.
Uh,
they do a EEG first and then they can
tell which of your brain are firing it,
what hurts in seeing,
um,
the congruency is in like how all of
that is happening or not happening.
And then they kind of prescribed these,
these different,
these machines like on your,
on your brain that make, uh,
these like electric impulses,
but they're magnetic to, um,
kind of speed up or slow down the
different parts of your brain.
So if the front of your brain is moving
slower than the back of your brain are
those or, or whatever. So, um,
they're noticing obviously, uh,
patterns with fighters, hockey
players, football players, like,
like people that are leading with
their heads basically. Um, having like,
uh, and then with the veterans that are
like emotional things to where I mean,
and yeah, and then like, I mean,
having to compartmentalize as well,
like some of the shit they see should be
upsetting, you know, and, and, you know,
but there's, there's different ways
that we can train our brain to,
to drop things like that.
And then PTSD is when it's an involuntary
and it all comes in and, and that,
so, you know, I, I've
been diagnosed with PTSD.
I had walked in there with medication
because of being depressed, uh,
and the anxiety and all of that.
Like my symptoms were terrible.
And I know they're a combination
of things, but even like
my startle reflex, like,
you know, I could hear
someone come walking around
the corner like clack, clack,
clack here, their shoes. But the
second I'd see them, it would,
it would stop my heart for a second. And
that's like shit on your adrenal glands,
you know, and, and, um, all
this stuff was, you know,
an anxiety that, um, I don't know. It was,
it was hard to fall asleep
at night. Uh, you know,
my memory was crap and this is all,
you know,
different stuff happening in all these
other fighters that I know as well.
But I mean, like I said, I've
been trying things so much,
so much over the past few years that I
get excited about and either it works or
it doesn't. And, um,
the, the point is, is,
is now I found this and I
feel better from this, but I,
I was so excited about all
these other things. Like,
I can't just start telling everybody of
the new thing that I've found because
I've said that and been excited about
like everything else with this one,
this one, like the equal
scope, it's like, uh, it's uh,
um, same thing. It's kind of like a tens
machine or stem machine, but like a super,
super low frequency and that's bad
ass to like it, it helped on injuries.
Like if I rolled my ankle or hurt my toe,
like you could bring the
swelling down from this to,
to normal essentially in like an hour
and a half just working on with this like
tens unit on it. And, and I mean,
they originally used it for
race horses and for, you know,
super expensive million dollar horses.
Like the equipment they brought over,
it was like 90 grand and like s like
these really specific like special metals
that were put into these plates and you
know, they would do stuff like that,
but that wasn't working on my head.
It was working injuries
and it was working on, um,
I want to say it helped with like my,
like digestive system maybe or my, um,
uh, I don't remember some, some
other things it was helping with too,
but what, you know, I,
I started doing that or I was doing that
when I walked into mindset and started
doing that treatment. And so what do they
do it? So you sit in a chair, you know,
and they ha they put this prescription
in this machine and the machine has kinda
got like a,
like a arm that goes on in a specific
part of your brain and you, you know,
you close your eyes and it sends these,
these magnetic pulses into your head.
And I mean,
you don't feel anything.
It's almost like you can
hear what it feels like,
but I don't know how to describe it.
It's, it's a sense, it's essential,
but it's not, it's not exactly hearing
and it's not exactly feeling, um,
yeah. And I mean you, you leave the
place after your treatment. Like I go,
I would go twice a day.
It's 45 minutes away both ways.
So I am driving a lot everyday to go to
do this cause I want to give it a fair
shot. You do it every day? I do everyday.
I haven't gone these past couple of
weeks cause uh, stuff with my kids. Uh,
schedule school's almost out and then
wanting to try out different things with
different coaches as far as
these new disciplines go.
So I haven't been there as much.
But um,
yeah for the last August I believe
is is when I was like really,
really getting into it and go on
twice a day and 45 minutes each way.
Twice a day. Twice a
day, yeah. So you would,
you would spend 45 minutes one way and
then go back again and then go back,
watch his fucking move
closer to where the places,
because the alliance was
down there and so I would,
I would drop my kid off at school.
I would run and then I would go there.
I would do my treatment,
I go back to practice down
in southern San Diego,
then I'd get my son and then we'd go
up there for the afternoon session.
And then I'd come back down and,
and we'd go to his sports and
then I'd have my second two a day
that does not leave a lot of free time
for cats and Ghana. Oh Hell No. Oh No, no.
Just that alone can be stressful.
But I was seeing the results.
That was the crazy thing
is I was feeling better.
The results when I just
walked in, like, like God,
like I couldn't sleep. I had just,
uh, anxiety, like I had that,
that startle effect going like
the, um, my memory was shit.
And these were all things that I went
to the UFC pie to talk to them about.
Cause I'm like, I don't know what
to do. Like I, I want to fight.
They offered me to fight Chris
Cyborg at one 45. And I was like,
yeah. And I was like, well, like
hell yeah, let's take that. But like,
can you guys at least help me get this
shit figured out first, please? You know?
And they're like, sure. Um,
so Dunkin French, he's at the,
the, he's, he's, he's, so he went to
college and t and was that an oh no,
he was at Notre Dame using
this treatment with the doctor.
I'm Kevin Murphy that
runs the mindset. So, uh,
he was like,
this guy is doing a lot of things with
people as far as brain health. He's like,
go see them when you get back to San
Diego, it's kind of far from you.
But like give it a shot cat. And I
called the guy, I'm on the phone,
super frustrated, like super
emotional. I'm like, I'm,
I'm at my wit's end.
Like I've tried everything I can
think of like holistic views,
like chemical views, this
like everything. I mean,
spending money out of my pocket trying
to figure this out because none of this
is covered by the UFC.
Especially because you know,
not something I claimed in a fight.
I mean,
I fought Amanda and if you don't
claim that stuff within the 30 days,
like you're on your own. And of course
my head hurt. Of course I'm dizzy.
Of course the lights are bright.
Of course. I can't think. Right.
I got in a fist fight, you know, and I, I
wasn't doing good in it for awhile, so I,
I figured, you know, but
then a month and a half,
two months out when I wasn't
better. It's like, sure.
Even though it clearly came from that
fight, you still don't get covered.
[inaudible] what? Not One. It's
endocrine stuff too, you know?
And it's like there's very,
there's like how could they
dispute that? That's where it came
from though. You go, hey, sit down.
I want you to watch something and
just play that first round. Go.
What the fuck do you think happened?
I don't know,
but I mean if you play
that video for them,
if any buddy in the insurance
business was denying you coverage,
saying that didn't happen. D while
you were under the banner of the UFC,
like you're out of your fucking mind.
Watch that video.
What do you think is happening while this
fucking assassin is throwing bombs at
your face? I mean that's it. That
is crazy. That that's not covered.
Yeah, that makes me sick. Oh,
it's frustrating cause bye by like
literally you look at the papers like it
costs me more to fight then,
then it, then I make Lucy now
makes sense.
If it was dealing with a broken hand or
a torn ligament or something like that,
it might make sense in Mike.
It does not make any fucking sense.
If you're talking about brain injuries
cause anybody who understands how brain
injuries work know that there's,
there's a considerable amount of time
after a fight where you still are
suffering from symptoms and you might
decide 30 days later, 60 days later,
90 days later you've got
to do something about it.
All right, well I mean now I know now
I come out of a fight and I'm like,
my pinky hurts, my elbow hurts,
my hair hurts, my eyebrow hurt.
It's like when a claim all of this,
you know,
because before I was just being tough,
you know? Yeah, I'm fine with fuckers do.
This is why it's so crazy and I didn't
like, I didn't get it and I didn't know.
And then,
but they should know if they're in the,
they're in the business
of insuring fighters,
they should have a larger window where
people can claim head injuries. Right.
Well that's, I mean that it kind of
goes together with like any kind of,
any kind of mental, anything. Like
any, you talk about mental illness,
you talk about head injuries,
you talking about Tbi,
it all goes into that stigma of like,
you can't see it, so it must not be real,
you know what I mean? Or,
or whatever. So it's like,
but that's the head injury
business. I mean, basically, yeah.
The point is to make
them drop and be done.
That's what everybody, I mean, it's not,
it's not the worst thing in the world.
The wind with a body kick or an arm bar.
But the reality is what people like is
to see head injuries were in the head
injury business. Right.
You know? Yeah. Yeah.
So how long after you starting with this
treatment do you start to see results?
So the first,
I would say the first thing I noticed
was my motor skills in practice.
And so, you know, I would go,
so you think your motor
skills were impaired?
No, I, well I just feel like I had
a block. Like I said, like it's,
it was comical and I mean you can even
ask them at alliance. And it was funny.
It was funny, but not to have
like we're in class, you know,
we're learning,
I'm watching the coaches,
like they do a drill and they explain
it and they look up. All right,
everybody ready? Ready?
One, two, three go.
And we clap and I have no fucking
idea what we're doing. You know,
like we walk off and I'm like,
like there was even a couple
of times where they're like,
they clap and they're like, Kat,
what are we doing? And I'm like, um,
three kick. And they're
like, no, 20 pushups. And I'm
like, man, I'm not even like,
I'm not just a bad kid
like talking and like, no,
let's say like I'm in trouble
because I don't hear you.
I can like not lose eye
contact the whole time,
like sit here and I'm like focused,
but no,
I'm not retaining it and less like if it
has to be the last thing that they do.
Like we can't talk about shit if,
if,
if it's the last thing I see I
can go do it, I could go do it.
But if they're like all right and then
they explained some philosophy about it
or do some movement or whatever, like
then I lose what we're doing. Like my,
my mind would just go
right to something else.
Like I had a very hard time
concentrating and you know, it's,
it's crazy because when I got to this
facility, you know, I didn't know,
I didn't necessarily know what I
was walking into. But they have,
you do this questionnaire and like on
this questionnaire is like all of these
things.
I'm like,
that's part of something like me not being
able to focus as part of something my
sleep,
that's part of something,
this startle effect is part of something
like me having these like completely
like specific things that are
all on. This was like, damn okay.
Like I didn't even want to see the EEG
because I was, I was scared. You know,
I was like,
what if you can't fix me and now I know
all the shit that's wrong with me like
that, that sucks. But then you know,
they show you different
egs and they show you the,
they take it every single week and so
you actually get to see it and you get to
see the level that you
were functioning at,
especially the different
parts of your brain. But then,
and the thing is that's awesome about
this is you get to keep the results.
Like unless you go do exactly what
you did and go fuck it up again,
like you get to keep it.
It's not like this maintenance package,
which is you know, a problem
for these pharmaceutical
companies. There's, there's,
there's not a whole lot of retention on
it because once people get their brains
functioning,
as long as you're not sitting there
hitting your head against a wall,
like you get to keep feeling better. Like
these, these veterans get to go back to,
to combat or whatever it is, their job
is like we fighters get to go back,
football players get to go back. Like
I, I sat in with the chargers, uh,
medical staff and talked about
our stuff there as well. I, I,
I don't even remember who else there was
people from all over the country coming
in asking about this, you know,
and, and needing to sit in and, and,
and they're looking at these egs
in particular. So what is it doing?
Like go, how was it fixing it? So
wine, um, I think it, you know,
there's something with what
goes on in your brain with,
with the thyroid stuff,
with the endocrine stuff is like getting
your damage to your hypothalamus. Right?
And that's like,
that kind of directs all of the
information that goes to your thyroid,
your thyroid, you know, then
sends out everything to your body.
And there when there's like
a disconnect there. Um, no,
it just screws everything up.
And then on top of it,
like now that we're cutting the
same way we've always had to cut,
but we don't get ivs. I mean, I mean you,
you cannot 100% rehydrate your
brain within 45 or 48 hours.
Like you can get your body
decently hydrated, I believe,
but your brain is just,
it's its own thing,
you know.
And so now we don't have ivs are hydraulic
system in our brain is down and now
we're rattling it even more
like dehydrated. I mean,
we're just going to have,
you know, bigger side effects, uh,
tire brains being dehydrated that now,
um, the damage that comes to the
hypothalamus to the pituitary, to the,
um, your thyroid, all of that that
goes on there, that, that they're,
they're saying that you can,
you can get it firing back at a level
that it was before it got hurt. Like,
as long as the cells are still alive
in it, they can reenergize those cells.
Now if you have like just a dead
part of your brain, you know,
they're not bringing it back to life,
but they can um,
use these magnets to kind of fluff on
backup, give them back their energy,
their, their life and, and put in a,
put them in back into a functional way
that was something similar to you at your
healthiest and,
and make it,
I mean not more or less durable just back,
right?
Yeah. When you, when you were saying
motor skills, like what was wrong?
Cause that's one of the things that
they see in fighters that have taken too
many shots. They start having
the, they analyze fighters,
gates and one of the things that happens
is your legs get closer together. Um,
your, your balance is off
your, your steps are shorter.
You don't have that sort of like dynamic
fluid motion to your body and you're
having a heart, a harder time
with balance and just motor skill.
Yeah, totally. So how I felt
before going into there,
it was all I had was the gas pedal.
I was like, just will, you know,
and just fuck them.
You know, just cause I,
I wasn't reading patterns
of people anymore.
Like if someone leans this way
a little bit, I'm like, okay,
I know what you're thinking.
Like if they set this way or that way and,
and even me juking them and like
trying to like faint at them. Like I,
I wasn't, I couldn't even see the
reaction I was making them make,
like I knew what motions in my
muscular memory to make them do,
but like I wasn't getting the feedback
because it, it just like wasn't,
so that was one of the first
things I noticed was, you know,
going back into practice and,
and watching people's angles
and beating them to it and, and,
and like remembering, I'm like, damn, I
don't just have to shoot to shoot. Like,
I can wait and do it when it's
the right time or I can even like,
like take advantage of, of
the fact that, you know,
I'm making them step back or I can flash
fire and they're facing and jump on
them at their knee jerk reaction,
you know,
like these things of like being able to
manipulate the situation and make them
adjust to me. Like I could see
that again and I could see, um,
would you him before,
like when I just had go,
all I had was when you
didn't see movement,
like say if someone was going to spin
and they're like we're loaded up their
hips. You didn't see, no, it just hit, hit
him first. What were you seeing? I all,
I didn't,
all I saw was get their first,
all I saw was like close the distance,
don't get hit in the head.
Like make like get down and get
low and just be a linebacker,
you know, and, and hit him because
I knew I wasn't seeing that stuff.
And the more I tried to see it, the
more I would just sit there and wear it.
Cause I'm like any minute now.
I mean any minute now I'm going to,
I'm going to catch the pattern,
I'm going to catch the pattern.
And it wasn't popping up.
So then all I had was just super
light sparring. Just moving around.
You didn't see it? No, no, not really. No.
Yeah, that's fucking terrified. I
was like, yeah, it was really scary.
And like even I'd even get to like a
good position in Jujitsu and I'd be like,
I know I know stuff here.
But she didn't know what to do. What was
it? What was it? What was it? I know,
I know stuff, you know? But like it wasn't
like, especially with adrenaline firing,
like it wasn't just happening for me.
And so like three,
four weeks into that,
all of a sudden like that fog was
starting to go down a bit. Right.
And like part of it was, and then, and
then I'm also sleeping better, you know,
to go before like during
like the first week. Oh yeah.
Cause every fucking person I went to
could fix me and driving 45 minutes.
Like what the fuck?
Yeah, yeah. In a, in a,
in a car I leased. So all
those miles, you know,
it's like damn. And um, it's
uh, it's super frustrating.
Yes. Everyone can fix me, everyone
can fix me. And then they don't.
And then my heart's broken again and
then I go to the next one and then my
heart's broken again and then, and then
the next one. So this one I'm like,
I'm like,
I'm not even going to tell people about
this because I'm sick of fucking hitting
up and being excited about it and
telling them to come with me and then it
doesn't work. And then I'm
that guy again, you know?
And so going into this and then watching
it work and then seeing all the other
people that was working for in there that,
and they were never trying to push me to
promote it. They were like, just come in,
just get here. You know, and
if you like it then until the,
cause the UFC was talking about getting
one of the machines at the Pi and
they're kind of going to have
me be like a Guinea pig for it.
Ian Mccall went in there too,
but it didn't like he,
he was doing his own kind of other stuff
that was making it so it wasn't working
for him, but like I was all in, you know,
that was making it so it wasn't,
I don't think he was coming in often.
So I think,
and the thing is is that it does stir
shit up, right? So like they, they,
they mess with your,
the the levels because again,
they have to like if the back of your
brain is running at four hertz and, and,
okay, eight is technically where like
you're sleeping, you're at rest like year,
there's part of your brains that could
be under your resting hurts, right.
While the front of your brain is running
at 12 so that's like high anxiety but
like low energy and, and, and they can,
they can almost tell you how
you've been feeling lately,
which was like nuts to me. Right.
And they can tell, you know,
because of this and this that,
that you have some OCD tendencies versus
this person constantly feels like they
have no energy in,
their memory isn't working and they're
emotionally and capable of like being in,
you know,
being a positive force in a relationship
right now cause I don't have it so they
could reach you should,
you should, you should.
It's scary though cause I cute when you
see that like little like and they're
like what's that?
But it's for me it's, that's
a two hour drive. Shit.
Yeah, I know that there, I don't
know if they have anything up here.
I know that they've,
they have a bunch all over.
That is what it's called.
I couldn't,
the website's not coming up but this
personalized repetitive transcranial
magnetic stimulation,
a noninvasive therapeutic approach to
the treatment of Ptsd and other neuro
neurocognitive disorders. Kevin,
Tim Murphy, MD, Vice Chair,
department of Radiation Medicine,
applied sciences, Uc San Diego Director,
Pediatric Radiation Oncology Program.
Uh, Rady children's hospital,
San Diego. Wow. Yeah. So that's
where you're going. And um,
I mean obviously during this whole thing
you have to be questioning what you do
for a living.
Oh yeah. Well, and it's like,
okay, so they can fix this.
Say they fix it and then I go do it again.
Cyborg. Right. I mean you were, you
were thinking about fixing it and you,
you were going from one girl who hits
like a dude to another girl who might hit
like a bigger dude. Yeah. I
mean cyborgs fucking terrified.
And it's like, I know healthy at
my healthiest, like no, no problem.
I believe that I believe in myself
like that. Like I can figure them out,
especially in find a way
to not get hit doing it.
Like I didn't get hit in my MMA career,
significant a hit,
not one significant hit and tell Amanda.
And then after that I was getting fucking
lit up. Right. And, and not even that.
Even Juliana,
like she kind of opened him,
bitch slap me a little bit from the
sides but I and but like I can find a way
to, to like still control
it enough to be like,
like very effective without taking
too much damage. But like that,
that slow of my, my motor
skills, my mechanics, it was,
it was really bothering me. And that's
not how you go fight someone like Cyborg.
You don't go in there with that
weight in your pocket. You know,
it's so important that you're
talking about this because this is a,
this is such a factor that
we don't see on the outside.
Other people,
you know,
other people than the people that are
really close to the talk to about these
things. Like if we were
seeing you fight and you know,
when we see the decline of
certain fighters, you know,
you see certain fighters,
they, they're in a couple really hard
fights and then you see it decline,
like a real obvious decline in their
skills and their abilities. Very,
very rarely are they opening up about
what's going on, about losing memory.
About not being able to see
patterns and people about not,
not having their motor skills in tune
anymore that things are off. You know,
so you talking about this I think is,
it's so important and it's so important
for young fighters to recognize like,
Hey, this is also on the table.
Here's a great therapy for it.
But this is also a possibility of,
you know,
if you do fight a fucking
killer like Amanda Nunez,
this is one of the things
that can happen to you.
Oh, and it's partially because I
have, man, I have teammates. Yeah.
I have people that are 10 times
worse than me that are just like,
I mean the stuff I hear,
the stuff I see, it's,
it's sad and it's scary and they have
kids and they're not going anywhere soon.
You know what I mean? And they're passing
their Mris, you know what I mean? Like
their MRRs cause what does it MRI
really see? I don't know. I don't know.
But if they went to this place and got
all their brain mapped out and find out
how everything is firing,
it might be a completely different result.
Like we might be retiring
people way earlier,
at least forcing them into therapy
way earlier as possible. Yeah,
I mean in that,
and that's the thing is it's like the
risk needs to be worth the reward and,
and you know,
like right now in this sport it's,
it's a juvenile and it's not
getting us like this kind of like,
like I,
I can't afford to take another two years
off because I went and I fought cyborg
while I'm sick and something bad
happens to me. You know what I mean?
Like I want to be sharp and if,
and if that means I have to take time,
take the time I took off off and get
healthy and do all of these different
therapies, the conservative, traditional
and nontraditional, like all of that.
And so I can feel the way I feel now.
Like I'm pumped and I'm excited.
But like that is something that I really
want to know that people know they can
go do. And it's not vulnerable.
It's not saying you're weak,
it's not something wrong with you.
Like,
like it's your health and your longevity
and your future because that shit,
if you don't treat it,
it doesn't get better.
And like you don't understand the
depression, you don't understand like,
and there's an identity that goes
away with, they see me and like,
you failed or you can't do it
anymore, or whatever. Like that,
that mental health aspect that comes
with the physical health of your brain,
like that, all that all needs to, that
all needs to be more educated as far as,
as these fighters go. As
far as all of it goes. Like,
I'm happy to be the Guinea pig because
I'm damn, I just want to see everybody.
Okay.
You know?
Well, I'm, I'm happy that you're
talking about it, but it's, um,
it's been something that,
you know, I've talked about
quite a bit and, um, the, the,
the real problems behind traumatic brain
injuries because I've had a bunch of
experts and I've talked to a bunch
of neurologists and I've talked to
neuroscientists and people that are
really studying this stuff. And, um,
I've been real vocal about it and it's,
it's a tricky situation because
obviously I'm a commentator,
but like when someone gets knocked out,
I'm very vocal about them
taking a long time off.
And it was one of the things that happened
after Rhonda got knocked out by Holly.
Um, they were talking about
getting her back within like,
it was like four or five months later
to to fight again and I was like,
[inaudible], we're going to have a
rematch with Holly. And I'm like,
you guys are fucking crazy.
Like you're crazy.
She shouldn't be doing anything.
She shouldn't be getting hit.
She shouldn't it be
sparring. She, there's,
she shouldn't be getting her head
rattled and she definitely shouldn't be
fighting Holly fucking home who just
kicked her into another dimension five
months later or whatever it
was six months later. I'm like,
there's no way this is not,
should not be happening.
Like you don't even know
what's going on yet.
You don't even know what kind of damage.
I mean,
think of what happened with you and
Amanda did you stayed conscious at least?
I mean, Rhonda got fucking flat
lined and then got hammer fist.
It didn't the head while she was lined,
it was uh,
one of the most brutal
knockouts in women's MMA ever.
And you know, and you saw when she
came back and fought Amanda and,
and got hit like right
away, that hesitation. Oh,
she was just stiffened up and the fear.
And then also Amanda,
I felt even before the Holly Holm fight,
I felt like Amanda was the,
the more dangerous fight for
her because of her hands.
Because Rhonda is always in this
position where she's closing the gap.
She's getting close to you because she
wants to clinch up with you and throw you
and take you to the ground and arm bar
you and what have you. But with Amanda,
you're dealing with a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
black belt who knocks people fucking
dead with one punch. Like it's
a terrible match up. I felt,
and obviously that true proved to be true,
but what drove me crazy was how dismissive
all these people behind the scenes
were.
All these agents and Hollywood people
and all these people that just have no
idea what business they're in, they really
don't even understand this business,
the business. It's basically
the business, like we said,
of head injuries and you're just like,
you're trying to sell
this thing where you're,
you're dealing with someone who had a
fucking significant head injury and now
you're pushing it back in.
There was someone who's really good at
delivering head injuries and is this,
is this really all been mapped out?
I mean,
what kind of training have
has changed? I mean, what you,
she's still with the same coach. Has she
done anything differently? Like what,
what do you think? What, what result
is going to be different? You know,
and the downplaying of the significance
of a fucking ruthless knock out like
that I just don't think
can be understated.
I think people should take a long time
off when they get knocked out like that.
A long time.
Yeah.
Well,
and I mean in especially some
sort of like invasive treatment,
like from out the gates
or something like that.
I looked at they should be
studied and I mean, I mean,
I know they put a flashlight in
your eyes and ask you if you okay,
send you to the doctor, do
whatever. But I mean like, and,
and I think honestly that's what the
UFC is like effort was in, in this,
in an offering. This information of this
treatment to me was to see like, hey,
is this something that would,
would benefit fighters in,
in a situation like that?
It's at the Pi. I, it's not at the Pii,
but what they were saying is it
would be at the Pi, um, still.
But the trick with it is that it is
something you need to, you need to go to,
I need you to go to twice a day and
have that like schedule of it in that
routine of it. But, uh,
says fighters like flying to only Vegas
for it and paying our own room and board
our own flight, potentially having to
fly our coaches and to have to, you know,
keep us working and doing whatever
while we're working. I mean, it's just,
I don't know. I mean, I don't know.
It's just tricky business. You know,
it's real tricky business.
And how old are you now? 35.
Do you wonder how much longer
are you going to do this?
I like, I feel like I got like a
good couple of years left. Like I'm,
I'm still having fun,
you know,
and like the chest of it is still fun and
like the training is still fun and I'm
still learning and like
enjoying it. And, um, I dunno,
like getting through everything that I'm
getting through and learning everything
that I'm learning is like,
it's so inspiring to me because
I definitely don't feel done.
Like I still have so much fight in my
heart and like I really love putting my
hands on people and in always
like advancing and improving in,
in the day I stopped
improving, you know? Uh,
then I can look at that. But right
now, like I don't care about plan B,
I don't care about what's next
because that's not what's happening.
So your passion for doing this
still there? Yeah. And the purpose,
the passion is, is huge. I love the
passion, you know, that to me is huge.
But the purpose, like the bigger
picture, the, the what I'm doing here,
what I was born to do,
what I was born to get through.
Like I have to get through this,
like I want to get through this
and I'm getting through this. I'm,
I'm watching myself and that is like,
it's bad ass to me. It's
exciting to me. It's, it's, um,
it's what I'm doing here, you know, and I,
um, I'm all in like in, in, I can make,
I can just make things for myself that,
um,
I get to show myself every single day
that like no one could have ever told me,
you know, it's all stuff
that I know firsthand from
my experience, from my world,
from me trying things from me, risking
things like all of that. And, and,
um, to understand myself
in, in, to know myself.
Like it's been the biggest
reward out of all of this.
Know yourself through the struggles and
know yourself through the fights. Yeah.
All of it. I mean, and even
how much you get to learn,
just even going into a fight, right?
Like, realizing, so going into a fight,
being on antidepressants like,
okay, I'll wake up, I'll wake up.
I don't know what this will do.
I feel flat. I don't feel flat.
I'll be okay with these people there.
I'll be, I won't be okay with this.
These people here,
like,
like all of that is very
clear about things that like,
this has my attention,
whether I know it or not,
that that's something
in my life that needs,
needs to be looked at and needs to be
addressed. Okay. There's direction.
Like all I ever want is understanding
and direction. Like, I just want to know,
you know, and so, um, I get
to deal with that, that,
that leads me to come to San Diego.
San Diego is,
is a new chapter in my life that
I get to name, you know, uh,
also for my kid and myself.
[inaudible] I get a reveal so much to
myself through trying different things and
to just kind of like letting life take
me down the path that I'm supposed to
without me sitting here
freaking out about control,
freaking out about things that I,
I can do nothing about. You know,
I just want to walk away from all of this
like content and happy with how I did.
Whether that means I never
have my hand raised again.
I don't think that's the case.
Like beating these girls,
having the belt that is not a pipe
dream. I already beat them, you know,
it's not like I'm incapable of that
and I'm just wishing I got my fingers
crossed. You know, it's,
it's not that my whole journey of my life
in sports from being a kid was to meet
my highest, best, to be
my highest good. And,
and that is what's
driven me the whole time.
I look at these girls and I respect
them because they're here doing what I'm
doing. We're all just out here
trying to be the best at it.
We're all trying to participate,
we're all trying to, you know,
find ourselves in it and learn what we
can learn and go implement it, you know?
And, and so for that, I have respect
for every single one of them.
Some of them I like less than others.
Some of them I like more than others,
you know, but, um, really like
we're building this stage together,
we're doing this together, you know,
and I'm, I'm extremely proud to be part
of something like this and my position
in it and my purpose in it is to,
you know, find my personal
good, my personal best.
And you know,
this has been extremely long road for me.
Nothing has been easy and I respect that.
Like I'm grateful for that.
Like all the things I know
because of the hard times.
Like I feel fortunate to know,
you know,
and I would never have learned them any
other way. And I get to handle them.
And not only do I get to handle them,
I get to like,
like relate and understand people and
see things differently because I get it,
you know, maybe not exactly word
for word pinpoint per pinpoint. Oh,
I'm having a chat to say that I
was going to make me fall over.
But you know,
it's,
it's all there and it all matters to
me and how I get through this really,
really matters to me because
I know it matters to other
people too, you know? And,
and how they do inspires me as well.
Do you know what you're going to do
when you stop? I, I just don't, I mean,
I feel like there's this thing is there's
this awesome resume and building, right?
You know, like I'm a UFC fighter, I'm a
national champion in wrestling. Like, I'm,
um, um, I don't know.
Constantly advocating and working on
working on myself and try and help get
other people working on themselves too.
Like,
I don't know what all that's going
to look like. And the thing is,
is I don't even want to,
I don't want to look,
I don't want to care about all that
yet because that's not where I'm at.
And like,
I want to be all in here.
I don't want to think about
what's next or plan B or,
or how all of like all of that because
my heart is here. Right. You know,
it's like what are you going to do in
your next marriage? Right. You know? Yeah.
You know what I mean? Like I,
I'm right now I'm, I'm, I'm here,
I'm doing what I'm doing.
I'm not looking towards what's
next because right now I'm here.
Yeah. No, listen, that's what you want to
hear from someone who's fighting. I mean,
fighting should be all in that study
is the only way to approach it.
If you're a fighter and you're also a
neurosurgeon to part time real estate
salesman,
good fucking luck.
You don't have 100% to give everything.
You got one 100%
especially with something like fighting,
it's just such a crazy way to make living.
You really have to be 100% committed
to it. It has to be your life.
Yeah. I appreciate the
opportunity. I like.
I like, I like everything I'm
doing right now, you know,
and I feel like all of that
will be part of what's next,
but I like that that'll manifest.
That will figure itself out. I don't,
I mean not to knock the like hippy
way of oh, everything will be great.
I'm sure like when it's time I'll look
at that. But right now this is what I'm,
I'm looking
at also the,
the kind of drive and discipline and work
ethic that you showed to become a top
level MMA fighter and a
national champion in wrestling.
You could do anything with that.
Whatever you set your mind to.
I really believe that.
I mean,
I think the biggest problem that fighters
have when they retire is finding a
thing to put their energy too.
And then their identity because their
identity is of a fighter and when that is
taken away from them, there's that.
And also the thrill. I mean there's,
you guys are experiencing a level
of excitement and intensity.
Like when you're talking
about two weeks out,
you're crying in the fetal position
and going, what the fuck am I doing?
But that all builds up to these moments
like that crazy primal scream after you
stopped Amanda Nunez.
That's a experience at very few people
other than people fight to the death are
feeling there's,
there's something,
there's something that you guys are
experiencing that unless you're the person
in the woods fighting over that bone,
you really don't know. You don't know.
And then for you to go to
regular life after that,
it's going to be hard and it's going
to be hard for a lot of fighters. It's,
it's very difficult for a lot of fighters
to find another thing that excites
them. The way finding excites them
because it's such a crazy pursuit.
And then on top of that you're
dealing with what you're dealing with,
but you're dealing with it
publicly. You're talking
about it, which I think is a,
you're doing a great service to
everybody when you're talking about your
problems and your issues because there's
so many fighters that you know that
they were experiencing this and that I
know that are experiencing this and you
know everybody who,
anybody who's done any sort of martial
arts competition and been in gyms,
you're going to see people that
have that have taken too many shots.
It's just part of the
game. And you, you know,
it's what you're doing by talking about
it so openly while you're still a top
level fighter is I think very,
very important for everybody. Huh,
thanks. I'm trying, man.
It's been allowed to try and things, but
I do, I do feel value in this. You know,
and I mean exactly when people are done,
like there's some pride in,
in having to go get a nine to five or
whatever, you know, after being a level,
a fighter at this level,
mind you should,
you not have the fucking brain
cells to be in. Like, it's like,
like I got high functioning thing that you
can be proud of. You know, I mean it's,
it can be really stressful to not live
up to the capability that, you know,
you have what you're just not like
there's that wall or that fog or whatever,
you know.
So I mean,
I just think people maintaining
themselves and doing everything they can,
however vulnerable it feels
like, fuck it. Do it. Like it is
well that they could spread
this therapy across the country.
And how big are these?
Yeah,
they have, I mean they look like
they, so they, they have, um,
like mobile units, but again,
like it would need to be on,
I don't know if it's on some sort of route
or whatever that people would need to
be able to show up to or
what. But um, they uh,
yeah,
I know they have one in Indiana.
I know,
I know they're going to have one in
Colorado soon I think relative to the
training center.
And when you say mobile units,
like how big are these mobile units
and are these effective as the one that
you're going?
It's a creeper van. You know, it like a
little dish of candy in there.
Yeah. It's like you get in and um,
it's the same exact chair, you
know, and then they have their,
they're trained to a nurse,
nowhere to put it on you. I don't.
And then even the Eeg, I mean
it's like a, it's a wireless EEG.
So I know that every week they make
you do the EEG, like same time,
a relatively the same time.
So they can keep good track of
what your brain is doing. And,
and how to prescribe the levels
to be at what on your head. Um,
and I, I think they have
one in, uh, Arizona.
I know there's one in Texas. Um, I want
to say there's 12 over the country,
but I can't tell you where.
And the mobile one. I mean, how big is
this? I mean, is this something that uh,
Jim could get and how is
it prohibitively expensive?
I want to say again,
I might be full of Shit,
but I think they're like
$100,000 for that machine.
But I do know that they're being, um,
insurance will cover it because, uh,
for the insurance will
cover it for Migraine,
uh,
PTSD and autism I think.
I think that insurance will
cover it for that, but then, um,
tricare's also accepting
them as an insurance as well.
Wow. And so when they're doing
this to you and you know,
you said you got it in August,
you started doing it and you started
seeing improvements after he said four
weeks.
Yeah, four weeks was like the
first time I saw improvements.
And then the bigger improvements
where caming leader. Yeah.
Does it, does it keep
getting better? I mean,
is it better now than it was last month?
Yeah, I mean, to the point where I
can, I'm, I'm okay not going for three,
four weeks, you know, like, like I said,
these last few weeks I've been all about
me getting everything right to be in
training camp right now.
So you feel right now like
you felt before the news,
right. In the way I'm changing. Like
I'm having fun with it again. Like I'm,
I'm watching people,
I'm like fucking with them.
Like I'll get them to step that way and
then I'll step that way and then I'll be
very satisfied. Oh my God. Especially
on for a while. Yeah, it was gone. And,
and like that is the art to me
is the games and the playing and,
and the like getting you to do this
so I can do that. And then, you know,
like that was what was fun. Yeah. Good.
Getting in a fight is not fun. Right.
But the chess, that's
what's fun. The game, like,
like making the oohs and the Ahs and
the crowd happen because you know some
gangster shit, you know what I mean?
Like that's fun. That part's fun.
Going in and getting cut up and bloody
and having headaches and like your ankle
hurts for a month and it's not fun.
No one wants to do that on purpose.
You know,
I want to go in and do what I can not
get touched and then have it go on a
highlight reel,
you know?
And that wasn't happening for awhile and
even on this last one, it was just like,
man, I felt better. I
totally felt better and, and,
but what I needed to change wasn't that,
that that was fine.
What I need to change as is other things
that I'm changing and I am, and again,
like if that's how I have to learn it,
cool.
But like it's all part of the process,
you know,
I'm not no second in this entire thing.
Have I stopped believing in myself?
No second. The only thing I worried
about was like, it was like, all right,
am I going to be,
is my son changing my diapers here in
a few years if I keep doing this shit,
you know, like, I don't
want that, does that,
but I never stopped believing that this
is what I'm meant to do right here right
now.
And I have time and I have more fights
and I have everything it takes to go out
and be every single one of these
girls. Some of them again, you know,
I do know now when you're in camp,
um,
how many days are you doing?
Two a days.
Yeah. So some of them are, it'll be like,
sometimes I'll have to add more
cardio in the morning. And so like,
if there's fasted cardio, if I'm heavy,
you know, depending on how that goes,
as it's like a science at about 45.
Like what do you walk around? Yeah.
What do you walk around? I can
get all the way up to like, I've,
I've been all the way up to 76, but that
was before. I didn't know that was when,
uh, I didn't, I was, I didn't
know I was hyperthyroid. Oh.
So then we now I was eating like 600
calories a day and doing fasted cardio and
two workouts in my weight wasn't changing.
My coaches were like,
what the Fuck's wrong with
you? I'm like, I don't know.
I guess the women in my family
get kind of big, so shit,
maybe it's just not Midwestern style
hitting me now, you know? But, um, no,
and then when I went and
I got my panels does that,
and like everything was all
screwed up, you know? And then that
Nunez fine before the Nunez five.
What was the heaviest I got before then?
I had never broke a
hundred. 150 552. Wow. Yeah.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Yeah. I walked around like one 40 I
didn't even have to cut cut for Misha.
I walked, I woke up in the morning like
two just didn't eat breakfast. Wow. Yeah.
And then now I'm a big Mama. Jamma
like how I look at food and I get fat.
No, but I don't hate it. Armour
thyroid or something. Um, uh,
leave levothyroxin. Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
I take it every morning and like 15
minutes before I can eat anything heavy.
You should look into armor thyroid.
It's a thyroid that's made
from a pigsty Roy. And uh,
apparently it's a,
it's more bio available.
A lot of people have better results with
it. I would, I would, I would try it.
I won't try. I wouldn't try
it now just cause I'm in camp,
but maybe in between the next ones.
Yeah. I'm hyperthyroid to really yeah.
Runs in my family. Yeah. My
family too. I didn't, um,
I have a weight problem cause
I was working out a lot,
but I was getting headaches and uh,
I went to a doctor,
get check at the end of the day, like a
say around like seven o'clock at night.
Um, uh, after dinner I would
be so tired that I just like,
I couldn't talk. I just had a lie down.
I couldn't hear it. I couldn't, Oh God,
we're going to talk. Boom. And
I'd go out and it was like, God,
these headaches are weird. Like this is,
it didn't seem, it didn't seem normal,
like the, the late, I guess it
was like after dinner headaches,
like right before bed,
it was just, it was,
it was not a normal exhaustion.
I started getting nervous about it
and then when I got to checked out,
it made sense and my mom has it. My
sister has it, it runs in our family.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's that
genetic for my family,
but you think it's from the head and I,
yeah, I mean it was right away. Yeah.
It was onset. And then, um, you know,
and then you do these Mris and you do
all of this other stuff and it's like,
all right,
well there's where your head hurts and
they're just what's wrong and you know,
so I mean, it was just, it's
all too perfect, you know,
puts together your camps,
like who decides what you're going to
do as far as like how much work you're
going to do,
what kind of training you're going to do,
where they're going to do sparring
or they're going to do, so
this training camp, um, I, I'm,
I'm outsourcing different things,
so I have like,
I,
I talked to Eric Delphia
about it and like I said,
I said I wanted to outsource the Jujitsu
and the Moy Tai and those are going to
in itself takes so much
time. Right. And then, um,
my strength and conditioning and I'm doing
with Chad missy is he's, he's mad ass.
Uh, so my strength and conditioning
coach, Lauren Landauer,
do you know who she is in Colorado?
So he's like family to me or
he's been there for everything.
Like I didn't even know when he got there.
He, but he was always there, you know,
um, he told me about Chad. Uh,
and so I started doing
strength and conditioning with
him. I'm going to do that,
um, three days a week. And then, um,
I know that I want to get working with
the more traditional Moitai again.
So I'm working with John
next two days a week, um,
and I think he's going to arrange
my sparring as well. And then, uh,
Andre Galvao I'm going to try to
work two or three days a week.
And then,
um,
so I handed all of that information
to Lauren Landau and my other coach,
my nutrition issues, Josh Ford.
Um, have you seen him before?
He's got like a tattoo
goatee on his face? No. Um,
he's been doing my nutrition and um,
I've,
he's known me since all I did was
Jujitsu, you know, so he's been around,
he knows my style.
He knows me as a crazy fighter and all
of that so close to between Lauren and
Lauren,
Lando and Josh Ford there,
they're putting it together based off of
what they've seen out of me in the past.
But if you're going to Jujitsu and you're
doing a lot of Jujitsu training and
then you going to Moitai and
doing Muay Thai training,
when do you get together
and do MMA training? Okay.
That'll be the sparring days and
then there'll be a light spar slack,
like Kinda drill day in
the middle in there too.
So are you sparring Moy,
Tai and sparring MMA?
No,
I'm going to be swearing mme.
So that'll be where I mixed together the
and like that's kind of how I like it
too.
Like I like doing the disciplines separate
and then and then me finding where to
put them in in a lot of times that's
where my freestyle wrestling just ties it
all together. So you're more training
would basically just be technique drills,
Thom Mayne,
a Ninja moves on that and
your moves and then Jujitsu,
are you going gear? No, gay.
I did know Gif or I did give for like
the past four weeks and yeah, fuck man,
shit hurts your feelings.
But then obviously it's more
practical to do with the,
to do the Nogi and now they
took the g off of me and man,
I'm like a thousand miles an hour. I'm
so happy with myself. Slippery. Yeah.
I'm like, you can't grab my
share. And what about wrestling?
Are you doing any wrestling
training? That part I, I will.
I still got to figure it out down in
San Diego. I want a freestyle wrestler.
I'm not like, I got a great shot, I'm
good at shots and whatever, but I'm,
I'm way more about throws.
Like I like there,
there's so much more efficient from,
yeah, I got awesome hips forum in.
It's just like, man, they're,
they're high risk, high reward,
but it's my funky style. Like
I just get them done. Right.
And it's so much less effort when you
taught someone over their head on the
ground and they don't know
where they are for a minute.
There's so much to capitalize on there
with the equilibrium just off. And like,
those are things I like,
like I count on,
so I need to find that
freestyle situation yet. Um,
I have good freestyle wrestling myself,
but obviously like,
like it's good to stay on top of those.
Like it's my strength,
but I need to keep my strength strong.
So I'm looking,
I'm going to make that happen.
So what do you walk around that?
Right now I'm like one 55 and 56,
seven 45 is a possibility.
Yeah. I mean, and I, I've,
I've wanted to go there as
well. I mean, like I said,
not having that fluid on our brains
when we fight kind of bugs me.
Like if I can walk down and one 45 and
eat breakfast, like, yeah. I mean I won't,
I'm like eating clean eating right
everything perfect. I'm one 55.
Yeah, because I watched one of the, uh,
they had a video of Cyborg cutting
weight to make one 40 [inaudible] which
didn't make any sense. There wasn't
even a weight class for one 40. Yeah,
they were,
I don't know what the fuck they were doing
with her or they were trying to prime
her for one 35 or seeing if
she could make one 35. Yeah.
But she was like weeping and it looked
like she was dying and like what the fuck
man?
Yeah.
Did she do the water cut and
that one like the, the bathtub?
Well she did a lot of shit
but it was just hard to watch.
And she gets big too.
Like they uh,
I'm friends with the way
I'll be who's her boyfriend?
And he like hit me up when I
was supposed to fight Ronda,
they were hitting me up during
my training camp. Like, Hey,
cause I think they have,
obviously they have beef and I think they
wanted it to be like kind of political,
but I'm just like not in to that. But
they were like, hey, how about Chris?
You do you have
any girl training partners?
How about Chris come train with you to
get ready for Rhonda? And I was like, oh,
maybe. I mean, how big is she? And they're
like, like, oh, one 82 and 83. And like,
what, what is the, how does that help me?
Another big motherfucker on me.
Like, Oh God. I'm like, um, thanks.
But like I got Neil Magni right there.
Dude over like these,
those guys are one 82 yeah, I'm not
paying her hotel. She so fucking big.
That's so crazy. I mean, she really,
she probably be fighting one 65 yeah.
And there there's a 55 you know,
common, hopefully. Yeah. I mean,
I just don't know. I mean, there's
only so many 40 fives. I mean,
she's obviously got the belt at 45 but
I think even 45 is a brutal struggle for
her. And you know, as you said, you
could only do that so many times.
It's taking a little bit of your life.
Every time you do that you're,
you're chipping away at Oregon.
Yeah.
And I just remember like,
I remember coming into MMA and like
I used to cut to one 25 like dying,
dying and that,
so I was,
I wanted to be ranked number one at one
25 that it was my goal before I moved up.
And like I, I did, I was ranked number
one, their beat everybody I could be.
And then it was just kind of like the
last time I made one 25 I just, I,
I fought a girl named to k Ohashi from
Japan and I remember it was like last
minute cause I suppose to fight a girl,
something happened to her and
then they replaced her with Tko.
And I just remember being so happy that
we were at altitude because I was like,
I think I had a heat stroke at the,
the water cut,
like the bathtub cut because I was
in the water for like 20 minutes.
And I remember at 10 minutes I was like,
something's wrong, something's wrong,
something's wrong. And they're like,
you have to stay, you have to stay.
And so the 20 minute line,
I like dove like a salmon,
like out of the water.
And I passed out on my floor and they
gave no shits that my managers there and
I'm naked and like I don't,
I don't know,
I'm out to the point where they're doing
the knuckle rub on my sternum, you know,
to try to get me up and then um,
I'd rub on your skin, you know,
trying to wake you up. That's
how they wake you up. Yeah.
It's like in your sternum. Yeah. Cause
it's like something with the nerves hero,
like hit your adrenaline
awake is crisis so bad.
And so I'm up and I'm like,
you know your hands and arms are
tingling and everything cause you're like
waking up, you know. And I'm like, I
don't want to get back in that bathtub.
Like put the sauna suit on me. I don't
like put it on me. I don't, you know,
so not that that like,
I mean health wise I was not okay,
but it was like I'm not
getting back in there.
So they put this on a suit on me
and my hands are like freaking out,
like doing this weird shaky like t rex
arm thing and cramping so bad in my feet
were doing the same thing.
But it was like,
like they had to cover me in the blankets
and put all of the stuff on me to keep
me hot cause I was not getting back in
that hot tub or the bathtub is terrible.
And after that, like I remember I
felt it in the fight and I was like,
I'm so glad we're at altitude cause I
feel horrible. I can't do this again.
And then I went up to 35.
Jesus Christ. Yeah. Yeah.
Is the worst part of fighting. It really
is. And it's so, it's so unnecessary.
There's gotta be, I mean, what one FC
is doing, they've got some, uh, they're,
they're eliminating weight cuts by
doing hydration tests and testing people
several times during the camp,
finding out what your way,
finding out what your actual weight is.
And Ben asked for him, went into, uh, the,
the, the way they're doing it in
detail when I did a podcast with him,
but that seems to be the way,
and they made everybody move
up a weight class essentially.
I mean, and that's the thing is I, okay,
like contract contracts can still exist,
but maybe you're just contracted as a
fighter and you have to fight certain
amounts of time a year or or whatever.
But to have people contracted
to weight classes is like,
it's hurting the sport and it's obviously
hurting fighters individually as well.
But like,
it's just unnecessary. Well,
you should do as fuck. I mean,
it'll be way more weight classes.
There should be more weight classes.
So there's more opportunities and you
should be fighting what you are when
you're healthy. It's
hard enough. Well, fine.
And I think especially
because the sport is, we can,
I mean it's very blatantly
clear that it's, it's,
this is not a bracketed sport.
Like this is an entertainment sports now
it's clear like we're doing what puts
butts in the seats, right?
We're doing what's best for
the fans. So at that point,
what are these divisions really matter?
It's about the matchup, you know,
you can throw a belt on it,
any fight these days, like,
so I think if we're going
to evolve the sport to,
to having entertaining fights
or entertainment type fights,
like we should just evolve
the, the contracts to that
as well. Like, shit, I mean,
it'll still save the entertainment
value. Like, look, you can get a,
or catch weights even like, what do you
guys want to agree on? You know? Right.
Like who's down for what?
If you had an ideal weight,
what would it be to fight out? Yes. Uh,
probably 45, 45. Yeah.
I feel like I'm skinny enough that I'm
like flying squirrel, flexible stuff,
you know, but, uh, but still a
hell of a strong, you know? Um,
but when you're dealing with someone,
like Cyborg is coming down from one 80.
That's the thing that was me healthy.
Like it don't matter. Like, um,
I'm the water, she's a
rock, you know? And that,
that's something I remember thinking when
I was going into 20 fives. It's like,
I'm going to be huge against all
these girls, you know, like they,
they may not be as dehydrated and fucked
up is me, but I can hold them down,
you know, and, and I can do
what I want and eventually
break them. Right. You know,
and she's, um, she's got that in
her back pocket too. Yeah. But like,
you know, you get the, I thought
watching the Tonya Avenger fight,
like there was a lot of things that I,
I saw in that fight against Chris and
I was like, damn, like that, that right
there, there's, there's, uh, there's,
there's something I could do there
to me seemed like Chris is being very
cautious and conservative and that she
was just picking her shots and just
trying to be very professional.
Like the way she was fighting was not
like this marauding rampaging destroy or
like we've seen in some
of her other fights,
she fought much more technical and just,
and Tanya evenger was throwing
wild fucking barstool type shit.
She was just, she, her hands were
down. She's whinging big bombs.
She knew she had to go for
broke. And you know, Tonya,
every Jew tough as fuck
just to take that fight.
I mean the difference in size was so
apparent between the two of them when he
saw them inside the cage and you know,
is just, just a really tough woman.
But her style, she was just trying to
be unpredictable and wild, you know?
And cyborg was just moving in,
let just real,
real professional and technical.
I felt like she was cautious.
I mean he was a big fight for her too,
you know? Yeah, yeah. That was the first,
was that the first
defense? What was that? No,
that was the first ballot because her
winning the belt for the belt. Right.
And then that didn't happen again. Yeah.
And there may, it was like, see Ya.
Germania randomly is like not interested.
Yeah. Wait, does she go there? She said,
oh she's still fighting.
Well she remember right after the fight,
I interviewed her after she won.
First of all, that fight bothered me.
It bothered me a lot cause she
hit Holly after the bell twice,
one hard and really rocked her. And
I watched that. I was like, fuck man,
that was a big shot.
And like you,
you could say you accidentally
did it once maybe,
but she did it twice and
one time hurt her bad.
And even so when I watched the
fight, I'm like, that's the, the,
the times when she hurt
Holly was after the bell,
but Holly fucked her up twice in that
fight. She hit her with that question.
Mark kick cracked her and rocked her and
then she hit her with a straight left
hand and dropped her too.
I felt like Holly deserved the nod in
that fight and I definitely think she
deserved the nod if you take points away,
which I definitely think
she should've taken.
She hadn't points taken away from her.
I just think I just didn't,
it didn't sit with me well, and then
after the fight she said she needed,
when I asked her about Cyborg, she's like,
yeah, I'm getting surgery. She's like,
I'm good. I got something wrong with my
thumb or something. So I was like, okay,
she's going to get some surgery. And
then, then it became a ped issue.
She said the Cyborg is
a lifetime ped cheater,
that she's a performance enhancing drug
user and that everybody knows it and
she's not gonna fight her.
So she basically just gave up her
title and went back down to 35 I think.
So she is fighting again.
I don't know if she went and got surgery
on whatever it was gone going on with
her hand, but she is going to fight again.
But she hasn't since I don't believe.
I don't think so. Anything, see if he
could find that Germane to random me.
See what she's,
who she's fighting next.
She hasn't tweeted since November about
a fight then. Damn, November. Yeah,
that didn't happen. See, that's the
person not investing in social media.
Are you doing it right? Are you
doing it wrong? No. No. She was like,
I'm just not interested in this anymore.
Which is crazy because this is how
fucking Tufts cyborg is Germane to random.
He fought a dude and coyote them. I mean
there's a Thai fight with her fighting.
Yeah.
I remember when I first started fighting
and like getting pointed at looking at
like that. Like, here's why you want to
learn white tie. And I was watching her,
I was like,
that girl is,
she's looking dance to some wars
and she's like older too. I mean,
I can't say older. I'm like one of the
older ones now, but she older than me,
but she, um, she fucked up a dude.
She Kao to is tray right hand?
I mean it's a,
I mean,
and then if she fought a guy like knew
it was a guy signed up to fight a guy I
fought on beat him and they're like
Cyborg. Yeah, I'm not doing that.
That's how scared she is a Cyborg
and I get it. I fucking get it.
Cyborg walking around 182 pounds.
I get it.
I mean,
it's a really open division one
45 right now and Megan Anderson,
it's about to fight.
Is that at 45 85 I believe that's it.
45 Megan innocence.
Big Girl.
But girl legit 45 [inaudible] she's,
she's strong.
She's in her prime. She's really tough.
She's good at everything. You know,
she's a legit girl fighting Holly
in her first fight in the UFC. Also,
it shows how much they think of her,
but I mean,
how many fighters do they have at
45 he's like fucking three mean.
Who the fuck is there? You've got
Holly who fought Cyborg and lost,
and then you know w what else you got?
You got Megan Anderson who was over in
Invicta and most people other than the
hardcore fans don't know about her.
You know?
And she was trying to get her name
out there. So what do we got here?
Is that the whole division?
The whole division?
Jesus Christ. Oh yeah, I know.
Well, Yana fought Cyborg.
She little, isn't she? She got
nuked. Yeah. That was a, I mean,
she did her best, right? She, when did
she fight Cyborg? Same night. I thought
she looked good until
Cyborg got ahold of her.
It's just like one of those things where
when Cyborg starts landing on girls who
see the look in their face, what in
the fuck? What am I doing in here?
I mean, I was most impressed with
Cyborg on her kickboxing loss when she,
when she fought jewelry and a barge.
Did you ever see that fight?
She fought her in Moitai Terina
bars is up fucking beast, man.
I need her. The room in the face.
Yeah. Bars knocked her down with a,
a front kick to the face and she dropped
her and still cyborg was still chasing
after her for every fucking round. Yeah.
I was like dot girls. I mean, she's,
she's big and she's strong and she's,
but mentally she's tough too.
Like she's, I mean to just a fight
that girl at during the bars had,
she had I think almost three years
without a fight where she couldn't get a
fight because nobody wants to fight her
because she's just a fucking bad ass Moy
Thai fighter real long and tall and just
classic Dutch style Moy Tai, you know,
and um, cyborg stepped up
fodder in lion fight. I mean,
when she was the most feared MMA
fighter in the world and said, fuck it,
I'll take a Moitai fight.
Like zero Moitai professional fights
fought like one of the best girls ever.
It's really pretty admirable. You know
how bad ass she is in that regard.
It's cool. But you know, when you
have a division that's that small,
it's like what, what do they
do? You know what I mean?
What are you going to grow the girls,
make them get bigger, like, hey,
girls want some food. Hey, you know,
I mean this isn't,
this isn't the pride days where they can
just fill them up with, um, you know,
whatever the Fuck Gabi Garcia is on know,
toss him out there.
You'd hate to have to be legit,
you know,
I don't know. I don't know.
Yeah. I mean it's, it's a,
it's a weird situation cause I, I mean
I don't, I don't follow enough to,
to know what is out there to follow
victor or do you pay
attention to any other, uh,
organizations outside of the UFC?
No. No. I'm going and honestly, I
don't watch the UFC that much either.
Cause I like, I don't have
cable. Like don't know,
I have Netflix and a DVD
player, like in school. Yeah,
we go crazy on eighties and
nineties movies. Wow. Yeah.
Well look, with Netflix, you
kind kinda don't, I mean,
you could watch good shit all day
long. You don't really, I mean,
so many people have
severed their cable now.
They just don't want to do it anymore.
Fuck a commercial.
And how much is cable? It's like a hundred
bucks a month or something like that.
What's Netflix? 10 yeah, something like
that. Like get the fuck Outta here.
And it's not like you
run out of shit to watch.
Like you could watch Netflix all day for
the rest of your life and never run out
of shit to watch. You know? It's a
weird time for those cable companies.
It's like the only thing that really
keeps people buying cable, I think. Or,
or direct TV. One of the big
things is live sports. Yeah.
Like live sports is like one of those
things where you kind of have to have
direct TV or cable or something
generational too. I mean, there's a
lot of people that just always had it.
Yup. Yeah, yeah, yeah. My
generation, these young kids,
they don't give a fuck about it.
Yeah.
John Young kids don't watch CBS and like,
see what the fuck is that?
And if the weird thing is if you watch
regular TV now it's seems like you're
watching a machine.
Like you're watching some,
some shit from like a bygone error,
like laugh tracks and then cut
to commercials. They're like,
what is this cliff hangers to
be continued? What is this?
This is weird. So what do you do when
you're not training other than the watch
DVDs?
I'm not really much like I'm trying
to get out in San Diego and like,
like live, you know, in play by the like,
I'll get to the beach when I can try
to soak up the sun and whatever. Um,
really like I have a struggle
because I realized I came here to,
to work.
Like I came here,
I changed in my life to come out here and
be all in and be as successful at this
as possible.
So my day is about training,
about doing the like rehabilitation
type things that I need to do and then
making sure my kids' needs are met and
you know, wash, rinse, repeat with that.
Like I recently went to like,
I've been to a couple escape
rooms. That's fun. Yeah.
They're super fun. Unless
you're not getting out, you
sit there and they're like,
hey, let's take your picture at the end.
I'm all pissed. I'm still here. Yeah.
Yeah. I didn't get out.
We didn't get out either.
We got out of one room but it led us
into the second room and we're like,
yeah, it's hard. I feel like
there's a, there's hard,
it was hard for me being an
athlete because I'm like,
there's harder we can do,
like I can work harder at this,
but there was no working harder at it.
Right. It makes you smarter. Yeah.
It's also like weird shit
to put pieces together.
Yeah. And then, um, let's
see, there's like a,
there's like a horse,
a rescue that I go down and I'll like put
time in down there and just kinda like
be with the animals and feed them and
like you can re try to rehabilitate them.
Some of them are scary man like,
but it's cool cause they're actually like
something really to be scared of like
half the shit we're afraid of
is just in our head anyway.
But there's this like gigantic animal
that doesn't know if it wants to kick you.
I love you. And it's like, you know,
trying to be friends so you can help
it and teach it. Stuff like that.
That's taken some of my time.
It's been cool.
That is weird with horses,
right? Like you could break them,
you can lasso them and they'll
let you ride them. Like fuck,
like wild horses. People go out and
catch wild horses and ride them around.
Like what other fucking animal can
you do that too? That's so strange.
You know like that is really strange
that you could like get a horse.
He got him in the bar and the horse was
like, fuck you, fuck you. And you're like,
no, fuck you. You get a rope around them.
And they're like, all right. All right,
you got me.
You're riding me around now.
It's very strange.
I mean,
it would have weird relationship
people have with fucking horses.
It's very strange.
Oh Man.
My friend Whitney Cummings
has a horse and she's all in.
She's all in with his fucking horse.
She rides it bare back. She's like,
you have to have a
connection with the animal.
It has to feel you like not a satellite.
Alright, crazy. Absolutely. I've
seen Clint Eastwood movies seems like
he's riding the horse pretty good with a
saddle on.
She doesn't do that.
And she rescued this horse and
she'd like on her Instagram,
she's always like riding around with this
fucking horse and hanging out with it,
you know? And she's like spending
all this time with it. It's like
it is, I they call it equine therapy
and like, like I was trying to get,
um, just because my brain was
working in all these ways,
like I got really excited
about that treatment center,
that, um, the mindset place.
And then again,
there's all those other people in there
that are in there and the veterans and
stuff. I was like, man,
if I could get someone them down
there working with these horses, one,
it gives them something to do cause the
ones that are disabled like their hate
in life and in that place,
like it's awesome because after
a few months of being there,
they all want to know how
to help their like, like,
tell me what I can do around here,
you know. And, um, even that without,
I'm like, man, if I could
even get them down there,
like sometimes if all you do at this
place has shovel shit, you know, it's,
it's still like you're around these
horses and um, this place in particular,
they're all rescues and it's called
Ferdinand's familiar and they've all been
mistreated at some point or they were
trained to be something that they never
graduated to being.
And so they were trash and now they need
to turn these horses into like rideable
like horses or whatever. Like that's
the goal. And then they have this, um,
it's near imperial beach. It's like
on that land, like right on Tiawana.
So you get,
the goal is to take them on this like
trail that goes all the way to the beach
and you can ride up and
down the beach like freely.
Can you ride the beach to Tijuana
or is there a wall? Oh yeah,
you can write it both.
And it's like a see through wall
and you see them in through, yeah,
I mean it's just like, it's like
panels. You can see right through it.
Like I went down there and you
could swim around it. Yeah,
I was thinking that the other day.
I'm like this,
you guys are almost too tempting.
Like I almost want to go over there.
Is it right here? Yeah, it's there.
That's exactly where we ride.
Fucking strange to me.
That is so God damn strange.
So which side is Tijuana? This is tia one
or the other side is the United States.
Right. And yeah, that's
exactly what it looks like.
They have their little umbrellas.
They're having their little barbecues,
like Chilean playing music,
having fun. Meanwhile we're
all over. They're like, Huh?
Like I almost want to try to swim over
just to see if anyone is going to stop
you because there is a little bit of like,
if you keep going up that fence,
they have like one car with
one dude who's watching,
who's watching the border patrol. And it
seems so easy to get here from Mexico,
right? All you have to. Oh,
and how deep can that fence go?
Yeah. How deep can it go? I mean,
it's put up here, put up your umbrella
and like a special angle and you're good.
We'll just climb.
This doesn't seem like it's impossible.
I mean, I'm not the best climber in
the world by fucking guarantee you.
I can make it over that fence a hundred
percent look. Yeah, you just grab a
whole the Av, some gloves on so
you don't fuck. You're hands on.
You're going to have to do some soft
soft sand Shane and cause that sprint
afterwards. Again, bend your
legs out. Yeah, the sports world,
but unless they're on Dune buggies,
they're not going to catch you.
Those fat fucks. I just, I
feel like swimming is the move.
Why climate? You just swim a couple
of hundred yards over. Yeah, right.
It's like 200 yards.
Maybe it shit go left and then come back.
It's so weird that like build that wall,
build that wall.
People are so crazy.
The whole thing is so strange.
I think one day we're going to look back
on countries like the human race one.
I think one of the things that's happening
to the human race for sure is that
we're getting closer to each
other. We're getting, we can,
like I'll read like tweets that someone
will post in Spanish or in Chinese or
whatever and you just press translate
and then you get to read it, you know,
translate to English. And
I'm like, wow, there it is. I
could read this guy's words.
And they have this thing called the
Google Pixel. Uh, it's uh, you know,
it's a phone and um,
they have these pixel buds,
these earbuds and these earbuds
will translate in real time.
Like you could say some shit to me in
Spanish and it'll translate it in realtime
to English.
Yeah.
And how long is it going to be before
that's way better and that we're going to
realize that countries are stupid.
See, but I think, I mean, I agree
on that on the social media side.
Like I feel like social media has
made that connection for us on that,
like that I guess mental,
social side or whatever.
But us as humans individually, like here
and now, right next to each other. Like,
I feel a huge disconnect, like
look at, I mean a century ago,
more than less than, like you knew
who the town butcher was, right?
He knew who the blacksmith was. You knew
who the mayor was like you knew like,
and everybody had their position,
your kids were safe to run around,
like everything.
Like everyone knew and there was
value to every single person for,
for what it is that they're,
their craft was or who they are.
And now no one knows anyone.
And like people don't want to like,
like I almost feel weird sometimes
that like, you know, my kids,
my kid doesn't see all of
the same pictures that I
see because I have Facebook
and he doesn't or you know,
but I'm not ready,
like to have my kid exposed to
the library right there, you know?
And it's a terrible thing for kids to be
exposed to. Yeah. And, and I think that,
um, you know, so like shoulder
to shoulder person, a person,
I feel like a bit of a disconnect,
you know? But social media,
like we get to share information
sometimes not good information.
Sometimes you get information like the
fact that people are communicating I
think is important. Um, it's,
it's making people take stands on
things that they're all finding out. Oh,
you believe that too? Or I think that
too, like cool. Like I can find my people,
you know, but on the actual
like oxytocin, like social side,
people actually getting
to know each other,
like those like intimate relationships.
Like I feel like that part is,
is suffering a little bit from it.
Yeah. I think that's suffering
a little bit in real life. Um,
because people were in cars,
they're in traffic isolated than they go
to work and then a cubicle all day and
they'd get home and they're in their
apartment or their house. Yeah.
There's not a lot of like interaction
with people and it's just stink.
This is just a side effect of modern life,
you know?
And it's weird that there's so many,
like in La,
there's so many people next to each other
and almost nobody knows their neighbor.
It's a very strange,
right.
But what I'm talking about is I think
countries are stupid, like states.
I think countries like states,
like I think we should build a wall over
Florida before we should build a wall
for Mexico. I mean, it's a,
Florida is a state, right?
But Florida is just as alien as like
say Finland or something like that.
I mean it's just, just the fact that
you can move out of Florida and like,
Fuck Florida, man, I'm going to,
I'm going to move to Atlanta and he'd
go up there and like, nobody stops you.
You just go. But if you're in
Tiawana like you like no dog,
there's a fence up your pitch like
this. No, there's no crossing did to,
to me that seems like super fucking
strange and almost like guaranteeing that
those spots are fucked forever and the
only way those anything's ever going to
level out is if you let anybody
travel wherever they want.
And nobody's willing to do that because
it might fuck up the good spots.
Like la Jolla would be like,
no, no, no. You can't just
like, yeah, we're not equal.
Yeah. You can't just come over
from, I mean you think about it,
La Jolla has some of the wealthiest
real estate in the world. Right.
And unbelievable.
Beautiful views.
And you could walk to Mexico
from La Jolla. You could walk,
I mean, what's the distance between
Tijuana and La Jolla? Let's guess.
Let me guess. I'm gonna
say it's 50 miles. Is it 50
I'm going to be 50 no, I, it's not that
many cause it's already it depending on,
oh yeah. I would say it's
a 30 minute drive. Like,
like moderate. Yeah. Normal
speed limit. Yeah. No traffic.
35 maybe.
So maybe it's 30 miles. So it's like
a marathon, like a marathon run.
Which people do. They run it all. They've
run marathons. All Tom 2030 to 32 miles.
Nine 30 so you're in fucking Tiawana.
You were in a third world country and
one of the worst neighborhoods of a third
world country and 32 miles away.
You have like these unbelievable mansions
on these bluffs overlooking the ocean.
Look Nigga, that shit crazy. That's crazy.
And Clara Natto it's very weird.
Yeah, exactly. It's very weird.
Yeah.
And, and yeah, that corn auto, the
island, that's all super wealthy people,
right? Yeah. That's where
Dick Cheney lives apparently.
Yeah. They, they have the ability
of shutting that whole island down.
If there's like vandalism or like,
cause it's,
it's got its entry and it's out like,
um,
what is it called way?
So it's not exactly an island
like it does attach to the land.
What does that call the
peninsula? Yeah. Yeah. So,
but they have an ability,
uh,
both the peninsula edge and
the bridge to shut it down as a community.
If Shit's going down on the island
and they don't want someone to
get off, that's how rich they are. Yeah.
It's only one of the wealthiest
places in the world. And another one,
there's one off sawed off of Miami.
There's like some little tiny island
that's filled only with rich people.
Star island, I think
so. It was called. Yeah.
It's like one of the most
wealthy places on the planet.
It's one little spot off Miami
just filled with rich folks.
Waiting for a hurricane to fuck up though.
Is that it?
Star island is a tiny neighborhood
of massive houses in drama. Oh,
there's drama. I only see the big x on it.
Like fuck this place. Okay. Got a drama.
Damn bad ass houses though. But
they have good brunch to, yeah,
that's a little too. So they have a little
bridge and it's a little tiny island.
All right. Good luck people.
Weird people are weird cat.
That's not safe. It doesn't
feel safe. Not in Miami.
I'm like that whole crocodiles,
the place is filled with pirates.
That place is filled with weird shit.
It's just Florida is so strong. I love it.
I'm joking around but I hate it. But
I love Miami. I just, it's so strange.
It's such a,
every time I go down there I'm like,
you should have to have a passport
to come here. This is not America.
I don't give a fuck what anybody says.
It's great, but it's, it's chaos.
But then there's some Florida
spots like we like, okay Pensacola,
if you just go fuck yourself,
would you say it's basically Alabama?
I might as well be.
It might as well we,
other than Roy Jones jr I mean he came
out of there. You put pence on the map?
Nope.
Do you do any boxing training?
I do.
So I um,
alliance has been real
helpful on my hands.
Like I would say there's a ton of
improvement as far as that goes. Like,
and I never really
focused on boxing before.
Like I worked Muy Thai and kickboxing
and between Dutch and Thai style,
you know, and then to go there and have my
hand sharpened was, was pretty cool. Uh,
I just never, um, I,
it was hard for me to like to relate
boxing to any sport I'd ever done.
And like as a, as a athlete growing
up as a kid, like if I don't,
if I can't understand
something that I'm learning,
I try to relate it back to some like
muscle memory of some motion I've done
before in some other sports like
volleyball or swimming or like what's the
mechanics of how I've moved in,
something that I can even dance,
like turned into getting like some kind
of value out of so I can learn this
thing. And like boxing was not like
anything that I'd ever done before.
Like you've never had a predominantly
hands on sport that I was good at.
So it's been the,
um,
the most, uh, what's
the word? I don't know.
There's the,
the most work in the less,
the least natural of all
of the disciplines. That's
a come into cause for this word,
but you've trained Moitai so much
tie his hands of it. Right. The
thing I'm excited about, the most
employee ties the clenching and the cakes,
you know, so to set up your wrestling,
right? Yeah. Right. And just having the,
the hips and everything with that, that
came with wrestling and that came with,
you know, the footwork of, of soccer,
of dance, of all that, stuff like that,
that contributed I think,
easily and translated easily over to that.
But boxing was, um, not so much, you know,
but part of me also thinks like, you
know, some of that had to come with,
with learning, like, you, you gotta get
hit to realize you don't want to get hit.
I'm like, I don't, I'm not ready. I
don't want to talk about that. Right.
Like I don't want to get it. So best way
to learn how to move your head. Yeah.
Yeah. And slip and roll with Shit. Yeah.
It hurts my feelings and get punched
in the face I'm sure. And I'm happy.
I'm the kind of person that it pisses
off, you know, like, so it makes me,
it makes me fight harder, you
know? But like it's stunning.
It is stunning.
Especially when you get one of those good
ones in the nose and now your eyes are
watering but you're not crying like that.
That weird stinging sensation.
Yeah. Yeah. Learning all of that,
that, that all was definitely within
the last few years and it's been,
it's been fun. It's been not
fun but fun. When you see like
the evolution, you know, a lot of
fighters are getting into yoga.
A lot of fighters are doing yoga.
A lot of fighters are finding that
they have like real benefits and uh,
protecting their back and strengthening
a lot of their joints and their
ligaments and stuff like that.
Yeah.
Do you feel like it's supplemental towards
like the physiology of it or because
it's something as far as
adding to the combative side?
Uh,
I think both.
I think for sure it's good for
your mental endurance because it's,
it's hard. I mean it seems like
something that should be very easy.
You hear about Yogi, like, oh, housewives
do that shit, but if you do it 100% in,
especially hot yoga,
you're stuck in that fucking box
at 104 degrees for 90 minutes,
sweating your ass off.
Yeah.
And I'm pissed at about 60
minutes and that one. Yeah.
So there's definitely some
mental toughness that goes
into the 90 [inaudible]
you endure, you endure a 90 minute hot
yoga class. But I think for your joints,
for,
for your range of motion and flexibility,
there's almost nothing better
because you're so, so hot and sweaty.
Everything's loosened up and do,
you can get into like deep,
deep stretches and deep poses and,
and also like for your foot
strength and posture and balance,
all that stuff is amazing. Amazing for
your back, strengthening your back,
your knees. Um, it's really good
for Jujitsu fighters. I mean,
Jujitsu people love it.
So one of the best things for Jiu Jitsu
because Ju Jitsu so static, you know,
so much of it,
it's like holding on and like trying
to advance position and slowly,
and then there's these bursts of uh,
you know, like explosive movements,
but so much of it is just
clenching and isometric. Yeah.
So much of it is that, and I think
you really benefit from being able to,
you know, in these yoga poses, holding
these poses for 30 seconds. When you're,
your body's burning and
you're, you know, you're,
you're having a difficult
time to standing up.
I think adding the heat
component to it too,
especially if you're a
weight cutting finder,
like getting to know your body and
in teaching it how to sweat, right?
Like this last training camp was pretty
awesome with that because I got a sauna
for my,
when I got us on a while ago,
I was using a red light for healing and
I was using the sauna because I know
that you can naturally boost your a growth
hormone if you're in that every night
and and help yourself
before you go to sleep.
So I was in that every night.
I tried to go in for like 45 minutes and
that was so helpful in going into the
fight week wait, cut. Because it was like,
I know what it feels like when it's time
to get the fuck out and I know what it
feels like when it's time that I'm like,
that sound like when
I'm dripping like crazy.
I still got another good 20 minutes of
me sitting here like this, you know?
And,
and I think it's really hard on fighters
when they're not in a sauna or that hot
for their entire camp and then they just
expect that out of their body the day
before a fight. Yeah.
I think you're right.
This is really,
really good benefits as you said,
two for recovery or reducing inflammation.
Yeah,
I thought it was hopeful.
I got a portable sauna to bring up
my fights with me. Oh that's nice.
Is it one you climb into and like
just your little head sticks out is
uncomfortable as hell cause you can't
lean against anything or it'll burn your
ass in the chair.
Yeah.
The chair is like this little half
chair and by that point you're like,
Oregon's are so depleted in and
you're like leaning all weird anyway.
So it was just hell.
But I mean it gets it off and you
don't have to leave your hotel room.
Oh that's nice too. Especially if
you're doing something on the road.
Like who was it that um,
somebody that somebody was
fighting somewhere and they
didn't have hot water and
they couldn't make weight because
they didn't have the, the bathtub.
I think it was a fuck.
I'm trying to think of who it was. Thomas
have been stressful. Yeah, they were,
I think they were fighting in Brazil and
there was no hot water for some reason.
Like the hot water was down and
they all like, what in the fuck?
And they couldn't,
they want one up not making weight.
I don't remember who it was.
I wasn't there for that event.
But I remember thinking like that is one
of the real problems with doing these,
some of these gigs in the road,
you know,
you're traveling to these places and
there's no fucking hot water if there's no
sauna and no hot water.
How he's supposed to make weight.
Oh, and it's awkward to be in
a sauna with your opponent too.
I fought Carina Damn.
Uh, again as a 2,400,
25,
like a few years ago.
There is Eric Anderson look
show was very respectful.
Damn.
Yeah. Yeah. The is Brazilian.
He knows. He was like, yeah,
yeah,
but we,
we were in North Dakota and we had to
go in and the same song in it became a
competition there.
I'm like,
God, I'm not getting out.
And when she, when she,
like there was a point,
like I'm sitting there with my coach
and I'm just like biting down yet,
I don't even know how long we were in, but
it was like hard. It was rough. And, um,
it's Kinda, yeah, exactly.
Like who's going to break
first? Who's gonna go first?
And she ended up being like, fuck
it. And she goes and she gets out.
And I was like, Oh, you have quit in you.
And I already knew I wanted to fight.
I won the fight. I was like, I saw
everything I needed to see. We're good.
Crazy.
That's so true.
Look, there's something to that. I mean,
you definitely don't want to die in there,
but there's, there's moments when
you're in the sauna, you know,
I have one here and there's this thing
that happens at like 30 minutes. We like,
what in the fuck am I doing? Well, you
start fucking weird now. You're like,
I gotta get Outta here. I gotta get Outta
here. It's like claustrophobia. Yeah.
Like you're, you know that
if you just opened that door,
this cold air and you're gonna feel great,
[inaudible] just lost someone
that asks you a question,
just hoping it just opens the door
for a second. Let's open a door.
Let me run out that door right there.
But that is what creates those heat
shock proteins is that your body realizes
that it's in this terrible
situation where your way overheated.
So your body starts creating
these anti-inflammatory
proteins and that's what's
so good for your body. They did a
study, I think it was in, was it Norway?
A doctor,
Rhonda Patrick brought it up on the
podcast that they showed a 40% decrease in
mortality from all causes,
from use of daily Sauna,
40% decrease in heart attack, stroke,
cancer, everything across the board.
It's unbelievably good for
you. Do you use the car? Yeah.
It's because your body
in reaction, the, the,
the response that your
body has in reaction to the
extreme temperature is just
to create all these anti inflammatory
properties and that's just so good for
your body. Inflammation is just the
root of so many different diseases.
And problems that we have.
Yeah.
So do you, what is like the temperature,
induration duration recommended for that?
I think it's 170 degrees in,
I think 20 minutes is what they want.
They want 20 minutes at 107 degrees,
170 degrees for um,
for, I believe the test
protocol was four days a week.
Is that the same statistic for
say like a Red Light Sauna?
It's a good question.
They didn't use a red lights on,
they didn't use an infrared sauna,
so they just use the traditional sauna.
But the theory is that it doesn't
matter because what matters is your body
reacting to the temperature change and
that doesn't matter how it's getting to
you.
They used a regular like hot rock sauna.
That's what I have regular hot rock sauna.
But I don't think it matters.
I think what really matters
is just extreme temperature.
And there's a lot of people
believe in those infrared saunas.
I think they're better. I don't
know. No, I just know your body,
your body likes sauna. Whenever I do
it, I just feel better sleep all good.
It's just better.
It just feels better for my brain to,
I just feel better about everything.
I just think it's just like getting your
body heat it up like that and then it
cools off. It just chills everything out.
You just, everything feels looser. Quiet.
There's like a quiet afterwards.
Yeah. But yeah, it just,
everything feels like it works better,
you know?
And then when I do it on a regular basis,
you know,
but I feel the same way about cryotherapy
when I do cryotherapy on a regular
basis to everything seems to work better.
Yeah.
See I,
I only do crowd therapy a couple times
and it hurt my boobs like so much that I,
I'm, I just, I don't want to
go all ice bath and I mean,
the thing is I'll get an ice bath
and I'm really like, I'll get in,
but I'm complaining the whole
way, you know? Like not,
not saying one nice thing
to you or your Mama.
Like I'm getting in there and I'll
do it when I'm ready and oh man,
it's awful. Awful. And those cryotherapy,
things like I appreciate the speed.
I appreciate like the,
but like do you really feel that they
get through all of those layers of skin,
like down to the optimal
level on your tissue?
Well, it's the same thing. It's cold
shock proteins. What happens is,
I mean if they really got it through
your skin, you'd be dead. Okay.
They're really got through though.
But the idea is that your body produces
these cold shock proteins in response to
anything that's over are
under 150 degrees below zero.
That's the sweet spot. Apparently when
you hit that hundred 50 degree below zero,
your body produces all these massive
in anti inflammatory properties.
Cause again it thinks it's going to die.
So it's like freaking out.
And people with arthritis and people
with severe autoimmune issues where they
have a lot of inflammation, real, real
problems with their joints in their hands.
They have huge results from cryotherapy.
And there's a bunch of people
that go to my place that um,
they say that it's really
essentially change their life.
They were just in pain all the time and
now they know all they have to do is go
there,
step in that thing for three minutes,
leave and they're going to feel better
and they just feel looser and relaxed and
whatever their flare ups and instead
of their condition deteriorating,
their condition improved and stabilized.
Thanks. So it's about your body in the
chemical value, not the cold itself.
Exactly. It's about your
body freaking out. Yeah,
go Yag is what does this bitch doing?
It's 150 degrees below zero oh my God.
And then when you get out of there, you
feel so good. That's what does it for me.
When I get out all my God,
I feel amazing.
It's like this rush of, it's just
the, what's it called, norepinephrine.
Yeah, you're, you have this
rush of it in your brain.
It's like you just took an awesome
drug. He's feel fantastic. I get out,
the sun feels great, people look better.
Everything just feels better. You know,
I do two sessions too.
I do three minutes and then I go out
for 10 minutes and then I go back in for
another three minutes.
That's how many times a week I try to do,
depending on how many
times I'd do the sauna,
I want to do one or the
other four times a week.
So either I'm doing the
sauna or I'm doing cryo.
So you don't do both in the same day.
Temperature manipulation? Yes, four time,
four days a week.
And if I don't do that,
I do hot yoga [inaudible] which is
another form of temperature manipulation
obviously cause you're 104 degrees and
you know, you're there for 90 minutes,
sweating it out. And that, uh, I
mean it's not as hot in the room,
but your body absolutely has that same
feeling that it has inside the sauna
where you're just like claustrophobic.
I gotta get the fuck out of here. Yeah,
I'm going to try it.
I'll try it. Um, I will,
I'm gonna send you this Emoji. Like
that's how you'll know I'm there for them.
One Sauna, I'm good. I sit in there
and I just turned up the jams.
Well if you look good,
the song and just stick with a sauna.
I mean I think that they're
both really good. Yeah.
What if I get in the cold shower
after the sauna is that account?
It was this thing
doing that too.
I like doing that after yoga,
especially in the winter when
the water gets real cold.
I like to get in that fucking cold
shower and just really large. Yeah. I
feel the two of them and you know,
the UFC has that set up to where they
have the Jacuzzi right next to the cold
bath that they got that cold plunge.
It's like set to below 50 degrees.
That's right. You hop in there, freeze
your ass off and then hop in the sauna.
Apparently there's like really good
benefits to doing that back and forth like
that.
Yeah, it was um, the last
fight out there is, uh,
I was sitting in that hot tub and then,
cause I didn't have the sauna, uh,
hooked up.
I just wanted to go in the hot tub and,
and then I laid on like the partition
and it had like one leg dangling in the
cold pool and one leg dangling.
And then the water's really good looking,
I'm sure. But when you're just starving
and dying and give no fucks anymore,
it's just like I'm laying there like that
Mackenzie dern was laying over there.
I look in the little worse than me,
but it's like, I guess, I don't know.
What did you think?
Would she miss weight by seven pounds?
Dutch shit's Kinda crazy,
isn't it?
It's crazy because she, like,
I was literally sitting in
the locker room with her,
like we're giggling at UFC two 22 like,
because we're both like curvy,
right?
And we're sitting in the locker room
laughing about how much that shit ways,
you know, and it's like, what can you
do about that? And even if you could,
do you really want to like,
I mean, I, I don't hate it,
but sitting in there and I'm
like laughing about it. And,
and that was what,
what was the date of that?
March 3rd and then to come down much
over like she got her fight right away,
announced right away. You know that
she was fighting me. What was it,
Nate 19th or something
and it was just like that.
Like when you have that data in mind, I
mean granted it's, it's not me, it's her.
It's, I don't have her body. I don't
have her problems. I don't have her life.
It's not my not,
it doesn't mean anything to me.
But to know you have a fight and
it's signed up and it's ready,
like at that point it's maintenance,
it's maintenance like that.
That's not even doing anything different.
It's just maintenance.
But like these weight cuts are harder
and harder on us. We get older.
I don't know what her body's
doing. I don't know. Yeah, she's,
I think she's 25 she's young and I don't,
I don't know. I don't know what that,
to make 115 pounds asks of her and,
and I don't know if she's
on her period or not.
I don't know if that makes a
difference to her. With me. I always,
I always get mine the
day of wins I have other,
I have like three other girls for other
girls that I know that it's the exact
same thing.
Like the morning of made way about to
go downstairs and there's that fucker
looking at you right then
just like there's why I couldn't lose it
last two pounds. Sweet. I would like to
the John Crouch about what happened
cause uh, he asked her to leave the lab.
Oh that was where she was at when
you asked, did she ever say why?
She didn't say why.
He didn't say why either.
They're both playing it professional.
I don't know what happened, but she was
long time too though,
wasn't she? Well like,
cause when I went to go train
down there, she, she was already,
she was there one in the days.
Yeah. I don't know. I'm not sure.
I'm not sure. But I know her dad.
He's doesn't he teach in Arizona?
Magnetite I think so. Yeah.
I'm hurt. Jiu Jitsu is fucking
nasty though, isn't it?
So gnarly. Woo. Yeah, she's good. We
competed against each other. Yeah. Yeah.
I was beating her ass. Well,
yeah. Well it was rough.
It was rough because I, I, it was
worlds, we were both purple belts.
I think it was the open division.
So I was like,
I was heavier than her by the
next weight class. And, um,
I,
I went to take her down.
I double leg are all big and
then like where we landed.
So if this is like the square,
we landed like right here.
And so they called it out and so they
reset us in the middle. So no points. Oh,
so we get in the middle because she's
Mckenzie because I'm not resilient enough.
Maybe. So I would, they start
us again. I'm like, okay, no,
did, I can't, don't go
near that line. Right.
So I go and I shoot another double picker
up, go take her down again. Same thing,
but like,
it's out of bounds again because it was
too close because my double is like a
tackle, you know? Right. And then, um,
so we go back in the middle
and we shake hands and we go.
So this time I go, shoot, I
pick her up and I look at the
ref like, like here, good.
Is this good? Okay. Put her
down here. Yeah. So put it
down, go to pass her guard.
And I passed. And then,
um, I think she had,
I sat back for a straight
ankle lock and they're like,
and they disqualified me. What? And
they're like, you can't have an ankle.
And they're like, you can't do that. I
was, I can't do what? And they're like,
you can't do that. And it's in
the rule books. I'm like, okay,
if I'm going to look in the real
rule books, what am I looking up?
What can't I do? Thank you. Can't,
you can't do that. You need to go,
you're disqualified. I'm
like, tell me what I did.
And they said that I reaped the knee,
but I like, I didn't like, I don't,
I really don't think I did.
You know?
So you think they were just juke in
the system to try to get her to win?
She's Brazilian. I don't
know. I don't know. It does.
And it's happened to some tournaments.
Yeah. And I mean they, they,
they sent, the thing is, is like,
I love Ibj JF tournaments and I want to
compete in them for the rest of my life.
Like I, you know, so,
but, but yeah, there is,
there is some themes that go on there.
Like there's definitely birthrights that
gets you places that like that I would
really like to have, but at the
same time, I don't really know.
I don't want to have been born into,
I want it to make the statement of like
happier birthright. Like, I got this,
you know, I made it to some pretty
bad ass tournaments in, in, you know,
just like fighting the way I fight and
trying not to give a shit about all of
that. And like I continued to do that.
I want to do the same, you know. Um,
but that was,
that was a rough one for me.
Like I was excited about that tournament.
I trained hard for that tournament
and I think we were each other's like,
I don't remember what match
into the tournament. It was
what to be disqualified.
And I was like,
but I still,
Carl specifically reaping the need.
Don't you have to go against the joint?
I don't know. I don't know. Like,
I wish I could draw you a picture,
show you a finger, Bang. Come up
with an excuse. We'll be, I mean,
the first two takedowns like we
weren't, okay. Maybe your first one,
maybe the first one. We were on
the line out fine. The second one,
like we hit the ground and then we
get it a little. So, but we were in,
you know, and then the third one, I'm
being a Dick, you know? And I'm just like,
yeah, yeah, here good. You
know? And so they like,
they gave me the points and then I pass
and they give me the points and then I
sit back for that and now I'm disqualified
and it looks like swallow.
It is. And I like her, you know
what I mean? Like I like her.
Her Dad was at my gym teaching
a seminar at my gym in Colorado,
like months earlier.
And so when the match is over and we go
and we're like standing next to them,
they're like,
sorry.
Did you see the video that somebody made
on Instagram of her after one day in
Liverpool? No. Do you know
people make fun of her accent?
That it's not real?
Oh,
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu one just told me
that recently that she apparently,
I don't know. I mean people
accents or weird to begin with.
Like why do people talk the way
they talk in the first place?
Because the sound with the people around
them. Geographical. Yeah. I mean it's,
it's weird, but there's a video that
somebody made of Mckinsey during,
after one day in Liverpool and
this basically her talking,
but Darren tills voice instead.
It's a rough, it's rough. I'm not
playing that. Don't play a JV.
Don't even pull it up.
I will not do that to her.
But it's pretty funny. Yeah, because I
was super confused when I interviewed her.
Um,
when she won in the UFC,
they wanted a translator and I was like,
what are you talking about?
Like she speaks perfect English.
Like this is really bizarre.
So George Greer Gel came
in, me and uh, he's like,
just in case she gets messed up anymore,
it's in like, I didn't even question it.
I was like, okay. I was confused.
I'm like, but wait a minute.
I know she speaks perfect English.
Like this is ridiculous.
Raised in Arizona right now,
but she fucking speaks perfect English.
So I don't know if they were selling it,
you know?
I don't know whose idea it was. I don't
know. I don't know. I don't get it.
But the fucking Internet. Got It. Okay.
Maybe they went, they went
crazy. Everybody was like,
what in the fuck is happening? I
didn't question it. I'm like, look,
I'm just here to interview her.
I just want her to, I mean,
she wants to speak in Portuguese, wants
speak in English. I don't give a fuck.
But I was like, why do you
need a translator? Like,
that's, that's insane. Damn.
I don't know all of that. I don't
know all that either. You know?
She definitely speaks
English really well though.
Does it? Is there a benefit to
not Brazilian? Well, yeah. I mean,
obviously that's a huge demographic
in this sport. Huge, Ooh,
primarily the biggest other
than an American American.
But I'm curious if there's
like a benefit or a marketing,
like is there there's or something
to that that would make that more,
well, Brazilians have immense
national pride, you know,
and her being a Brazilian and the daughter
of a Brazilian Jujitsu legend and you
know, and speaking perfect
Portuguese and English and, and just,
I guess maybe that's the idea behind it.
I don't know.
She's killing it though.
Like technically and with her style and
I mean like everything that she brings
to the table is, is already good. You
know? It's like don't fuck that up.
Don't fuck with it. Some. Yeah. Who knows
what your dad again. Yeah. I don't know.
You know what?
Sometimes when I get around people,
like I feel bad because like I try
to be like really empathetic and,
and when I'm around like foreigners
and like I will totally slow down my
speaking,
so they will get it to the point where
sometimes I think I look condescending.
Right. You know where I'm like,
I just want this conversation.
Who is easy as possible for you because
I'm already awkward and like let me help
you out. You know? That's a
different thing. But it's like,
you remember when Madonna had a fake
English accent and everybody was like,
pitch, you're from Brooklyn or
wherever the fuck you're from,
not from England and you can't
do that stuff. Yeah. I mean,
depending on who she's around, I guess.
I don't know. Fuck. That's the thing,
like if you're around people that have
that accent, you'll, you will pick it up.
Yeah.
When I was a kid,
I definitely had a Boston accent,
but I heard myself talk on TV once
when I was like 19 it was a Boston bag.
No,
I've got to get rid of that.
Like how did I pick that up so quick
and my family's all Minnesota rural,
you know?
And so when I go home I get that and it
will stick around for a few weeks. Sure.
Especially if you drink, right?
Yeah, for sure. I'm real tired. Yeah.
Or You have your round. All those people,
it's like comforting. Accents are funny.
It's strange.
You know they're,
they really are strange that
the like specific to regions,
it just shows you how people are,
you know, southern accents and even
like England like you have like,
like very,
very different like British accents,
which I'm sure to them
sounds exactly like,
you know Texas versus versus need work.
You know,
just the different twain.
Yeah.
My friend's wife is from Liverpool and
she was trying to explain scouse to me
like the way they talk and
Liverpool versus the way
they would talk and like say
London and let y'all sounded English
to me. You might as well be Australia.
And I was like, I don't get it. I get
that. You sound different than me.
I don't get what's happening though.
I don't get the accent until
like somebody like, like,
like Darren tills clearly has
like that Liverpool accent.
It's so clear. But I don't, I still don't
get it. I don't know what it is. You know,
you can say he's from London.
I'm like, oh, okay cool.
English, English isn't there?
Is it like that or like whoever was a
rain there had like a list and so then
it'd be set and then that ended up
being the people picked up as like,
was it a compliment or
just how it happened?
Cause that's how things were like
pronounced when they were being explained.
Like,
I don't know,
maybe there's some kind of like speech
impediment that went along with every
different dialect.
And I mean that is what it is with Spain,
the way they pronounce certain words is
because like some fucking king somewhere
along the line had a list.
Strange, strange shit.
Did you know that a place in Brazil
that has a list also? I forget. Really?
Oh I'm not, I'm sure there must be
like different axes. Brazil, right.
Brazil is fucking huge. I mean definitely
different singsong type tones. Tones.
I would say more. Yeah. Did you
ever, uh, train down there? Yeah,
I've been down there I think three times,
four times to train to chain
in the visit. I did. Uh, uh,
I wanted big old Jujitsu
tournament down there before. Yeah.
I think it was like Brazilian
nationals, something like that. So we,
I would go down like get
fully ready to train,
get there the day before and cut because
once you're there and then compete the
second day I was there.
So the rest of it's vacation cause it's
like once you're there, all the food,
all of the like beach and like lazy,
like there's nothing in me that
wants to work hard as I could do.
All I want to do is just enjoy the music
and the sounds and the people and I
know how to cook down there. Those two.
Haas Korea's holy shit is brilliant.
Brilliant. Well you guys have them in
San Diego. They have them everywhere now.
Thank God.
But a style of cooking is the best.
Those skewers oversight over fire. That's
what I'm talking about. Meat over fire.
That's it. That's it. And then the
little sauces, like the creations,
just oil and lime and, and seasonings.
So good. Talking to more, you won't make,
wait. Oh my God. I'll always make, wait,
I'm just a little bit
more dead than others.
Why is cap cut off her leg?
We just did two and a half hours
time just flew by. Right. So,
um,
good luck.
Good luck in, um, in Boise. I'm
looking forward to seeing you fight.
I'm very excited and I'm glad
we finally got a chance to
do this. And, uh, it's, uh,
is it causing Gunno MMA on Twitter?
What is your,
do you know it?
She's got to check her phone.
I know how to send stuff out,
but I don't know what it is.
Uh,
it is Alpha Katz and Co at Cat Zingano.
And then on my Instagram, it's Alpha
Cat Zingano. And then Facebook.
It's cat Zingano,
MMA fighter.
Cason Ghana. Ladies and
gentlemen. Thank you. I'm glad
we finally did this. Alright,
thank you. My pleasure. Bye everybody.
Hm?